uh good evening and welcome to this
meeting at traffic council's Planning
and Development development management
committee my name is councilor barium
Stanley and I am the chair of this
committee before we start the meeting
proper can I ask everybody in the public
area is intending to film the meeting
okay brilliant thank you in an event we
are being broadcast on the council's
YouTube channel
continuing on to my immediate writers
councilor Lawrence Walsh who is vice
chair of this committee to our left and
right our Council officers from planning
legal and highways
down both sides of the table or members
of the committee who are all local
councilors I'll introduce them as they
speak
to the agenda item one attendances to
note our attendances as we just have and
to note any apologies we have a policy
this evening from councilor Maitland and
councilor Taylor Council Acton and
councilor Evans are attending as subs
thank you councilors
item two
Declarations of Interest members to give
notice of any personal or prejudicial
interest and the nature of that interest
relating to any item on the agenda in
accordance with the adopted code of
conduct does anybody wish to give a
councilmanis thank you
um yes so item um uh
109953 which is the 121 Park Road
um I've had I've been part of a lot of
discussions
um with residents and I have a fixed
mind on the and I'll be speaking against
so I'll take myself over there to then
do my speaking thank you okay brilliant
thank you anybody else receive an
interest application
um I do a lot of voluntary work with St
John Vianney I'll be sitting out that
application when it's discussed thank
you okay thank you councilor anybody
else
great thank you item four questions from
members of the public uh we have no
questions from members of the public
this evening
item five additional information report
to consider a report of the head of
Planning and Development to be table
that the meeting that reports has been
uh so tabled item six applications for
permission to develop and I've realizing
without the massive on the agenda going
back to item three minutes to
approve the correct record the minutes
of the meeting held on the 15th of June
2023 can somebody propose those minutes
please
thank you counselor somebody second them
thank you councilor 30 minutes are so
accepted
back to item six applications for
permission to develop uh we have seven
here tonight the process is the same we
need a case the item is introduced by a
member of the planning team if we have
speakers on the item then speak next
members of the public get three minutes
Ward members get five minutes
I'll then open the item up for debates
to members of the committee only and
will then come to a decision by a
majority vote
thank you so the first item on the
agenda tonight is uh Homestead one two
one Park Road in timperley Miss Milton
will give the introduction and it's on
page 69 of your pack thank you
thank you chair
the application relates to development
of land currently occupied by late 19th
century villain known as Homestead at
121 Park Road temporary the building is
currently vacant having previously been
occupied by a community center
temporary library was also accommodated
at the rear of the site during the
development of the new library building
in timpley Village The Villa is
recognized by the local planning
Authority as a non-designated Heritage
asset the immediate surrounding area is
residential comprising Bungalows
two-story houses and three-story houses
being developed on the adjacent site at
119 Park Road
the application proposes the action of
five three-story dwellings following the
demolition of the existing buildings on
site with off street parking provided to
the front of each unit
for the proposed new properties will be
served by the access road 119 Park Road
while the property to the front East
Side plot 5 will be provided with a new
access from Park Road
the application is reported to the
planning and development management
committee as more than six
representations have been received which
are contrary to the recommendation to
Grant
in total 63 representations have been
received from different addresses 60 of
which are in objection
the main objections relate to the loss
of the existing building and the impact
on Heritage loss of the community
building scale and design of the new
dwellings impact on residential amenity
an increase in traffic and Highway
Safety and loss of trees the
significance of the non-designated
heritage heritage asset derives from the
bill is architectural and historic
interest including its historic
Community use nevertheless the building
is not considered to be so unique and
its setting has been diminished by his
historic use ceasing these factors all
contribute to the assessment of the
building as sitting at the lower end of
the spectrum when considering
significance and Heritage value
The Proposal would however result in
demolition of the villa and therefore
total loss of significance resulting in
major harm to the non-designated
Heritage asset the site has not been in
formal Community use for at least five
years since its closure as a community
center the building has been in
commercial use the resultant provision
within the new timpley library and near
built by Lark Hill Center with regards
to community facilities as such the
property is not considered to constitute
a valuable Community facility in regards
to the National planning policy
framework
in terms of design the three dwellings
to the rear of the site would match
those being currently developed at the
rear of 119 Park Road sharing the access
road and creating cohesive Frontage more
decorative and detailed elevational
features are being incorporated into the
dwellings to the front of the sites
plots four and five to better reflect
the Heritage building of Homestead as
well as the more traditional buildings
along Park Road
the pro proposed development is
considered to be appropriate within the
rider street scene with a staggered
building line
and part 5 incorporates a two-story
element
adjacent to the to the Bungalow to the
east of the site thus creating a
sympathetic stepping down in height
the proposed dwellings would meet
adopted guidelines in relation to
distances to rear boundaries on
acresfield Road
however it is acknowledged there would
be some loss of light to bedroom windows
in the side elevation of the Dormer
Bungalow at 125 Park Road however these
are not considered this is not
considered to be so significant to wear
a refusal the proposed development would
have an acceptable relationship with the
approved development at 119 Park Road
and the standard of accommodation and
amenity space to be provided for future
residents exceeds guidelines in relation
to National Space standards
having regards to the previous use of
the scientist Community Center a more
recently commercial commercial use it is
considered the level of comings and
goings associated with the new dwellings
would not exceed the vehicle movements
previously associated associated with
the historic use of the site
the proposed access arrangements are
considered to be acceptable and
furthermore it is considered that the
level of traffic generated would not
result in an unacceptable impact on
highway safety
the loss of trees and hedges is
considered to have a detrimental impact
on the visual amenity of the site the
submitted landscaping and planting
details will provide adequate softening
and screening for the development but
without offering the significant visual
amenity the existing prominent trees
currently provide and as such further
investigations are required and
conditioned in regards to seeking to
attain existing trees to the front of
the site and that condition is reflected
in the additional information report
as the council does not currently have
an immediate five-year housing land
Supply the Tilted balance identified in
the National planning policy framework
paragraph 11 D2 would apply the proposal
would create five new family dwellings
in a sustainable Brownfield location and
therefore
as only five units would make a limited
contribution towards the borough's
housing Supply but nevertheless
significant weight is given to this
housing contribution the development
would also provide a small economic
benefit during construction
there are many three main harms stemming
from The Proposal regarding the loss of
the non-designated Heritage asset the
impact on trees and the impact on
residential amenity however in weighing
the planning balance substantial weight
is given to the contribution to the to
the housing Supply within the borough
especially given the shortfall
the exercise under the talent sword
balance has been carried out and the
adverse impacts of the scheme would not
significantly and dimensionally outweigh
the benefits When assessed against the
policy in the framework as a whole the
application is therefore recommended for
approval subject to the conditions
worded in your report and additional
information report thank you
yeah thank you miss me I'll know we have
several speakers on this application but
first we have a written statement from
one of the neighbors Holly glazebrook
which will be read by Ms Lowe Miss
Lowe's thank you
thank you chair
a written statement on behalf of Holly
glazebrook of 125 Park Road objection to
Homestead 121 Park Road temporary
non-designated Heritage assets timpley
Community Center is a non-designated
Heritage asset the property is one of
the few remaining buildings in timpley
from the 1800s with distinct features
surrounded by mature trees it has
historical aesthetic and communal
significance this Heritage asset makes a
substantial contribution to the local
character and appearance of temporary
forming a huge part of its identity as
evidenced by over 600 signatures
received via repetition to stop the
demolition
the proposed plans would mean the total
loss of the non-designated Heritage
asset would have which would have an
adverse an irreversible impact on
timpley once it's gone it's gone the
benefits of five additional housing with
the probable asking price of more than
half a million pounds does not outweigh
the irreversible harm that will be
caused this beautiful building and the
community as a whole
housing shortage as outlined in the
committee report the main reason for for
the recommendation was due to the
shortage in housing within the area if
this has upheld the community has to
suffer the total loss of a
non-designated Heritage asset
development should meet the needs as
effectively as possible
to
the
2021 census confirmed the average
household size in Trafford is two with
31 of the population in a two-person
household only 7.1 percent of trafford's
population have a five or more person
household which would require four
bedrooms
the development consists of five bedroom
plots or four bedrooms plus playroom
however you want to dress it indicating
the level of housing shortage served
would impact less than 1.7 of residents
if this development were to maximize the
opportunity to meet housing demand as
required by the committee it would
consist of accommodation from one or two
person households which covers 60.8
percent of traffic's population as per
census clearly the more affordable or
how house the more effective the
development would contribute towards the
housing shortage scheme
this would also fulfill the quota to
offer affordable housing when 10 or more
housing houses are built the development
as it currently stands is not addressing
the housing shortage
if the community is to suffer the total
loss of a non-designated Heritage asset
for Housing Development it needs to be
reasonable for the community the design
and layout should be appropriate in its
context
design and amenity protection street
view context on either side of 221 Park
Road there is a Heritage Property all
doctored surgery and eight Bungalows
with adequate drives and Gardens to put
the development into context the Lander
house ratio is disproportionate if
compared with neighbors pre-development
the same size plot houses two dwellings
only however the development proposes
five times five bedroom houses a new
road and 13 car parking spaces
until I finished her
and this is over development and
unsympathetic to the area the
development is disproportionate in both
scale density height and massing to be
clear the development proposes buildings
are three floored five-bedroom house
next to a Dorma Bungalow this is
overbearing
okay thank you Miss love uh councilors
Minis and for us which everyone has
decided to speak first could you press
the microphone
thank you councilmanis
I know you know this but with the
benefits of the people in the uh in the
public area you will get five Minister
speakers award counselor uh if you uh
you'll hear the beep go once you've
reached your five minutes and then if
you carry on I'll ask you very politely
to finish your comments okay thank you
Council minutes thank you chair and
fellow members of the committee
this plan seeks to demolish as you heard
a non-designated Heritage asset and
replace it with housing
firstly we have the destruction of the
non-designated Heritage asset which was
gifted to the people of timpley it was
built in the 1800s
it has been an integral part of Simply
Life from being the recording studio for
Frank's sidebottom to hosting some
Affairs for families
being our library and functioning as a
community center
which brings me to the second point
I personally have attended some Affairs
and toddler groups with my children at
the site
with the loss of the United Reformed
Church on Woodlands Parkway community
space is now reduced is that a premium
um outside of of this and and the day
job I play the violin in an amateur
Orchestra we make we used to meet at The
Woodlands Parkway uh church and we had
to find another venue which was quite
difficult to find one for our group
we did manage to find one in the end but
we had to make a number of concessions
as also another thing I do in life as it
were is a beaver scout leader I
understand the importance of community
space
the pandemic has laid bare the need for
social interaction
to keep people in better Mental Health
humans are social creatures
these need to be in walking distance of
people's houses and homes so that they
can go and actually socialize with their
local community
this application does not seek to
provide any community space as any form
of mitigation
so even if you were to decide that
non-designated Heritage assets is not
that important we don't seem to have any
form of provision of a community space
as a mitigation not that I think that
that would be acceptable but I think it
would be some form of mitigation
the neighboring property at 119 is
another is also a non-designated
Heritage asset and as such applications
develop it when it came to when it came
to council
um a while ago and that included
demolition of the bit of the um old
doctor surgery
um they weren't entertained because
obviously we wanted to keep the
non-designated Heritage assets and the
logic was that the building had to be
kept
um that it be returned to its former
glory which is being done and um
obviously the scheme has included other
homes but
primarily the actual the Heritage asset
has been retained the scheme to develop
um this site at one two one that retains
their asset their Heritage asset and to
bring it back to his former glory and
respect the Covenant that that is placed
on the land of how many how many
buildings should be there would be a
welcome
application thank you very much
thank you councilor minis Council frass
thank you
again you'll get five minutes from when
you begin to speak thank you councilor
thank you chair you've received
representation from residents and other
committee members about the background
and the impact that this proposal would
have were it to be built so for my own
part I shall attempt to address some of
the specific points in the report this
evening as you might expect I've reached
different conclusions so I will invite
you to agree with me paragraph 14 states
that the site has not been used as a
community center for many years and the
report presents this as evidence as a
lack of community support or interest in
the site this is not correct we've had
more than one representation which
outlines how there is an unmet demand
for Community spaces but deliberate
policies by the council have forced the
building to remain severely
underutilized in the first instance the
site has not been well advertised for a
number of years more specifically we see
in the representation listed in the
report as seven linsgate drive that
several Community groups have indeed
taken the initiative to approach the
council about using the building but
have been refused and I was told by
officers a year ago that they were
tasked with moving out the two
organizations using the center and their
requests for long-term leases were
declined
so these actions mean that the building
has been half empty for a few years
which in turn has allowed for the
statements in paragraph 14 to be printed
giving the misleading impression it is
underutilized because there's no demand
whereas in fact this is becoming a
self-fulfilling prophecy paragraph 14
further States there's plenty of
alternative provision in places such as
Lark Hill
on this I will revert to personal
experience
finding a space to book a room for a
meeting is incredibly difficult and
simply the library staff have told
residents that room bookings should be
for Library related activities obviously
there are noise restrictions and a
library hardly making it a place for
something like the old film club and in
any case it is closed half the days of
the week lucky as we are to have the
Lark Hill Center it's one room which is
rarely available because it's so popular
so I'm not convinced the conclusions on
the viability of the center are correct
paragraph 17-35 deal with the
non-designated Heritage asset paragraph
34 for example says it is not considered
to be so unique in direct comparison to
the retained Villa next door which is
the doctor surgery
well so what our heritage asset
designations being rationed are we only
allowed one per Ward
but since the paragraph in number 34
forces us to make comparisons to the
building which was saved next door it
presents us with a perfect example of
the Heritage designation being respected
the property being retained and
incorporated into the plans for the
Redevelopment of that plot and I urge
this committee to consider that as a
stipulation for the plot at one two one
as well
finally I'll draw your attention to
residential immunity walking along that
side of Park Road your attention will be
drawn to the fact that the properties
are all Bungalows or Dorma bungalows
now let me step back in time not to the
Victorian era when that place was built
but the year 2000 when a few plots
further down norweb wanted to build on
the site of the old electricity
substation
the council's planning department here
rejected those plans saying that
building at the back of a plot like this
would be out of keeping with character
of the area and would have a detrimental
Immunity on the occupiers of Neighbors
eventually the land between 131 and 139
was developed but with low rise Dormer
Bungalows the character of the area is
still the same today so why are we now
saying in paragraph 67 that the impact
on residential amenity of buildings
three-story house next to a bungalow at
125 is acceptable when before only
Bungalows are acceptable
paragraph 10 states the housing need
assessment identifies the strongest need
is for three bedroom houses easily
accommodated in low-rise building
instead of a five bedroom house on three
stories which isn't going to solve any
affordable housing crisis this is a
question of scale and massing and it is
too much for an area of bungalows
thank you
thank you councilor before I go to the
officers to get some remarks on the um
the points made already is Mrs philcox
in the room
thank you Miss Phil Cox if you approach
the microphone you'll get three minutes
to speak once you start to speak and as
you've heard several times already this
evening if you go over your time I'll
plan to ask you to finish your comments
thank you
thank you chair
good afternoon councilors
um my name is Ellie of you and Kelly
Property Solutions and I'm here with our
client pick homes to present the
application today
as set out in your office's
comprehensive report the application
relates to the Redevelopment of one two
one part Road
the site is currently occupied by 19th
century Villa known as Homestead whilst
the building has been in community use
in the past this used ceased in 2008.
the application seeks the demolition of
the existing building and the
Redevelopment of the site for five new
much needed family homes
the new homes have been designed to be
of the highest quality and incorporate a
number for sustainability measures
including both PV panels and air source
heat pumps
all of the new homes have been designed
to be accessible in line with building
regulations part-time for one visitable
dwellings
pet homes are a locally based developer
committed to Bringing forward high
quality schemes
they're currently delivering the
development of the adjacent site at 119
Park Road and as you'll see a few more
from your offices report they Pride
themselves on being professional and
considerate development developers which
has been recognized in the letters as
support received
whilst we recognize the concerns raised
particularly those in respect of the
loss of the existing building it is
important to acknowledge the options
including the retention and conversion
of the building have been fully explored
and would not be viable in part due to
the condition of the existing building
in addition the ReUse of the building
would not respond to local housing needs
specifically the provision of family
homes in this location
notwithstanding the client and
Architects have worked collaboratively
with both your planning and conservation
officers and the proposed dwellings to
the front of the site have been revised
to capture the significance of the
building which is to be demolished
through the inclusion of architectural
details such as clints string courses
finials and decorative Ridge tiles
other changes following feedback from
officers include reducing the size of
properties fronting part Road and
increasing the amount of landscaping
included across the frontage to ensure
the development complements the
character of the area
as a result the proposals before you
today represent the highest quality and
most appropriate development of the site
turning to other considerations detailed
technical assessments have been
undertaken to support the application
and there are no technical reasons which
would prohibit the application being
approved
to conclude our client is committed to
the delivery of the development and has
worked positively with your officers to
bring forward a well-designed scheme
which will make a meaningful
contribution into the council's
five-year housing land Supply through
the delivery of much needed sustainable
family homes
with consideration to the quality of the
scheme and the benefits highlighted I do
hope the committee is able to support
your office's recommendation and approve
this application today thank you
thank you Miss Wilcox before we move to
involve the members uh Ms Milner can we
have some comments on the points raised
I think particularly around
um the Community Asset and the Heritage
effect thank you
um yes sure I'd also just like to pick
up a comment from councilor frass in
regards to the Bungalows on the old man
website and that permission was from
around 2000 and therefore was made under
a very different policy context and
furthermore it wasn't a scheme and we
sought to approve and was allowed on
appeal so the weight we would give the
comparison to that is very limited
in regards to Heritage the comments
regarding 119 are are noted and 119 Park
Road is considered to be
of much greater significance in its
architectural appearance and it's highly
prominent within the street scene and as
the previous doctor's surgery was
considered to make a significant
contribution to the area
with regards to non-designated Heritage
assets the national planning policy
framework says we must weigh this in the
balance so as we've tried to to kind of
set out in this report whilst one two
one is a non-designated Heritage asset
we've tried to distinguish the
difference between the two of them and
say they are at different levels on the
scale of significance or scale of
contributions they made to the carriage
for the area and we feel that 119 is of
much greater quality which in the
balance did
um warrant retention
in regards to the Community Asset we do
look to the mppf which says we must plan
positively for Community spaces and as
um the landowner the council they have
planned positively in regards to
Temporary library and
the the library is now within Central
timpley and therefore this building is
no longer required for the council it is
now a redundant asset and so the
landowner has sought to dispose of that
that is not a decision that we can
revisit as a planning committee that is
a different decision what we are looking
at is the land use and weighing that
against the planning policy before is
which is set out in the report in the
National planning policy framework so we
have weighed that in the balance and
weighing that in the balance against the
non-designation Heritage asset and
um the quality of the scheme we feel
those benefits do outweigh the harm
thank you Miss Milner any member wishing
to speak
Council currently
thank you chair
um obviously there's a great deal of
support for this as a Community Asset
but I think that's been dealt with
pretty well by the officer just then
that leaves me viewing the sort of
historical act
um aspect of it
and it's mainly the front
which isn't particular I'm not won over
by the the Heritage aspect of this
particular building I think and I think
the officers have done a good job in um
assessing that
um
it's a front of the current building
that contributes to the attractiveness
um overall the planning balance is very
much in favor of this scheme we need
houses and like
if we can't just keep rejecting things
but that are not properly used the main
aspect of the societies car park that
hasn't been mentioned in any of the
submissions is primarily a plot of car
parking that isn't used
and I want it used and I want it used
for good quality housing and I think
this application is an excellent quality
of Housing and I thought I'd really
struggle with myself if I was to vote
to cancel this application so I'm very
much support and I'm happy to propose it
oh can I add one thing that I did pick
up the uh paragraph 83 there's a
recommendation to Inc put something
about permitted development so that
um carports and the like are
have to go through an application rather
than being permitted but I couldn't see
anything in the conditions that dealt
with that
it is um
13.
condition 13 said she can't I must
suggested thank you
councilor Evans
thank you chair
um I find a thank you to councilor frass
uh so eloquently yeah
put in the case to protect this
Community Asset
um I think he's right it does feel like
the uh there's been delivered I don't
wish to criticize the Council on
deliberate policies they put a
management company in charge of this six
seven years ago that Managed IT so
disastrously badly that they ended up
getting evicted from the unit Council
just did the purpose of the committee is
to look at what's in front of us I know
that the history has been mentioned but
we have to look at what's in front of us
how we got that it's largely irrelevant
to the work
you say that it is a community you try
and book I did I did you say that sorry
I did just say that it's just we need to
concentrate on the the scheme that's in
front of us back to you councilor well
if if we're not going to focus on the
loss of the Community Asset then to be
perfectly honest there is no point in me
speaking but Council frass uh eloquently
exhibited why it is a Community Asset
and it is needed it has been actively
run down when we needed a uh space to
put the library in it was there for us
um the applicant suggested it's been
dormant since 2008 that is patently
wrong at the film club and the maths
tutors numerous others were using that
up to just pre-pandemic and it was quite
thriving and busy Community Center it
does feel like it's been actively run
down and there are Community groups that
are booking places in Bowden the larkilt
is booked up the library is fantastic
but its facilities are
only suited to certain groups and I
think it is a terrible loss and the
space a small amount of effort would
have this let out and it is a community
so so it isn't what's going up it's more
the loss that timpley will face and I I
would say that as an ex-timberley
councilor for eight years I know this
building I know the people and I know
the loss to get 63 letters of objection
it was 63 letters thereabouts is is
quite something of certain planning we
don't get that and so I I will not be
supporting this thank you Jeff all right
thanks councilor my point about the
Community Asset was not that you're not
allowed to talk about the community
assets of course that's what we're here
to talk about today my point was uh
expressions like the deliberately run
down and really without outside the
remission this committee thank you
councilor councilor Brian
yes um I would like to
um support this uh development
um I'm uh in my day job I work in
housing and I'm aware of the demand for
larger family homes right across greater
Manchester
um
and in timpley in particular uh there is
a large I demand from for family type
property
um
I accept that these properties are
likely to be expensive however
the way the housing market Works people
in lower value properties are likely to
purchase these and therefore vacate
those and make them a more and increase
the availability for
um
first-time buyers and so on to to get
onto the property ladder
it's uh just something that's very much
needed in in timpley in my opinion and
these are high quality
and attractive and well thought out
houses and very much needed so
um I would second
cancel accordingly okay thank you
councilor did anybody else wish to speak
[Applause]
Council welcome
thank you I don't have too much to
um add to what's been said already in
support of this scheme I think it is is
a shame to lose this this building
obviously it's always best to uh uh to
use the embodied carbon in a bit that's
in a you know in a building and I think
this this particular building it's just
a victim of its location right that
couldn't be more Central on the site if
it wanted to be so you know so it's very
I think it would be very difficult to
create an alternative scheme around it
that includes includes more units
um you know if it was at the front of
the site I don't doubt that a quality
building like that would have been used
and uh you know and they could have you
know
done what they're going to do to the
back of the back of the site and I just
think that's really that's really
unfortunate
um because it you know that building
could have been made into decent into
decent properties but you wouldn't be
able to use the rest of the site I mean
I've just got her in my mind the Tilted
balance in my head and I just think that
that's this is a clear example of the
Tilted balance we have to we have to
provide our housing Supply as um
requested by the government and and this
brings five units in there are and and a
lot of the reasons I I totally
understand the the very large number of
objections to this but a lot of them a
lot of them are not on planning reasons
that this committee can
um you know that could use to possibly
object to this and and therefore we have
to you know we we have to be responsible
and and look at those playing reasons
see if they hold up and on this occasion
I just don't think they do so I will be
um voting in favor of this thank you uh
thank you councilor Council Baba
um
while I have you know a lot of
sympathies for all those you know who
made representation uh particularly you
know will tell us the emotional
attachment of the property but on
balance and you know on all the reports
um I would be supporting this
application and you know in page 70 if I
may mention this that
value added so amended plans have been
received further to discussions around
the design the amendments are summaried
as follows so that clearsy tells us that
there have been you know communication
and recommendation by the officers which
have been you know regarded accordingly
so I think on balance
um you know it's a good proposal to
proceed with thank you ah thank you
councilor yeah I mean I I looked at this
proposed in great detail I was I visited
the site I have great sympathy with the
the fact that it's uh it was at some
point a community as a community center
it is no more and we are desperately in
need of the land so it's uh it's being
proposed and seconded that we proved
this in live officer recommendation
could all of those in favor indicate
please
thank you
all those against
okay we voted to approve battery life
officer recommendation
not the next item is
um Saint John Vianney School in
longford's on page 157 of the pack and
Miss low for gave the introduction
do you need me to read anything else
[Music]
thank you chair
this application relates to the
Redevelopment of the school at St John
vianney's re School
the application sites comprised as a
special educational needs School within
the Old Trafford area the existing
School accommodates 160 pupils with 70
full-time staff
planning permission is sought for the
Redevelopment of the school with no
changes to pupil intake or staff numbers
the development will be funded by the
government's School rebuilding project
owing to the poor physical condition of
the school and many of the buildings at
the end of their lifetime
thank you
the replacement school would achieve Net
Zero carbon in operation and
construction and demolition Works would
be phased to allow the school to remain
in operation throughout
this application is reported to
committee because more than six
representations have been received
country to officer recommendation
these representations predominantly cite
the construction impact upon the
surrounding environment and where the
contributions can be sought to improve
the adjacent alleyway
these conditions have been duly
considered and detailed in the officer
report
[Music]
officers are satisfied that the
construction impacts can be mitigated
through appropriately worded conditions
and the additional information report
updates condition 18 to further
strengthen the construction management
plan condition
this requests additional details in
respect of vehicle track tracking and
how Vehicles would enter and exit the
site in forward gears and requires
further details on the construction
management with particular reference to
the impact on pedestrians and cyclists
in addition a new condition is also
proposed requiring a detailed
construction phasing plan to be
submitted
both of these conditions require the
details to be submitted to and approved
by the local planning Authority before
any wax can take place on site
in respect to securing any contributions
to improving an off-site Alleyway
adjacent to the site and as set out in
the report would not be necessary in
planning terms and would not comply with
the legal tests and therefore is not
does not form part of any of the
mitigation for this scheme
in line with the mppf officers have
attached great weight to the delivery of
a suitably constructed school which
would provide specialist education to
save the needs of the existing community
such as design amenity highways drainage
air quality and ecology are all
considered to be acceptable subjects to
appropriately worded conditions
the application is therefore recommended
for approval thank you
uh thank you Miss large we have several
speakers on this but at first we have a
written statement to be read by Miss
Coley from uh Miss Campbell thank you
thank you chair this statement is quite
long so I may not get through it in the
three minutes if it gets to the end I
will try and just very quickly summarize
anything I've not got to thank you
a statement from Claire Campbell on
behalf of Neighbors at house numbers 98
to 106 Warwick Road South
narrow cul-de-sac section of Warwick
Road South consists of our five houses
and Saint Hilda's Primary School the
majority of us do home-based work or are
retired some residents have Mobility
difficulties our homes are directly
opposite the construction site our road
is connected to Oswald Road through a
narrow Alleyway this alley acts as an
important access between Charlton and
firswood consequently our road is a busy
pedestrian and cycle route it also
provides the main access to Saint
hilders these unique features mean that
the road has multiple functions by
almost every transport mode everything
from pedestrians to refuse trucks there
are resident parking bays and double
yellow lines parking access is difficult
and contentious around school drop-offs
and there are often crunch points with
the different transport modes in
addition the road surface is in a poor
condition
for confirmation we have used every
channel available to us to raise our
concerns about these proposals this
includes contacting our MP and World
councilors responding to the public
consultation in December meeting the
developer in January when we reiterated
our concerns and submitting
representations to planning following
our meeting with the developer we were
informed of a small tweak to the
construction phase this was communicated
me on the 6th of February I would like
to highlight that we have had no contact
whatsoever with the developer since then
I highlight this because I understand
that the impression has been formed that
the developer has been in consultation
with residents this is not correct
concern One Construction route
our road will act as the access route
throughout the three-year construction
seeing up to 20 wagons per day using the
road as well as up to 80 construction
workers entering the site this
residential road is not designed to
accommodate this pressure we anticipate
that it will cause significant detriment
to our ability to use and enjoy our
homes
we are very concerned about risks the
physical safety of pedestrians and the
multiple Road users from the hgvs as
well as from pollution and noise we
anticipate significantly disrupted
access to our driveways and additional
damage to the road surface from the
heavy traffic
The Proposal sites a new double gate for
access directly opposite our homes we
are very strongly opposed to this
temporary entrance as it means hgvs will
be regularly maneuvering in close
proximity to us
we do not understand how large
construction vehicles will be able to
turn safely into the newly formed
entrance and note that a vehicle swept
path analysis has not been provided with
the application there's also no
information about the size of
construction vehicles to be used we
believe the plans are not appropriately
detailed or developed to allow the
committee to properly consider the
traffic management issues we believe
that there are the viable access routes
onto site which should be explored we
would ask the committee that in the
event of approving the application
stringent conditions are imposed in
relation to the access to the site and
the management of associated
construction traffic
concern too suspension of parking
restrictions we are strongly opposed to
any proposal to suspend parking
restrictions we reiterate there's been
no mention from the developer or
consultation with us about a change to
parking Arrangements and then there are
then another few concerns concern three
is the design of the elevation opposite
their houses
um
and uh then another concern about the
lighting of the scheme which is uh dawn
to dusk lighting then a concern about
landscaping and then a conclusion they
submit that the proposal should be
rejected in its current form thank you
chair okay thank you Miss Conley uh
councilor German okay to take a seat
and you will get five minutes from the
moment you begin to speak thank you
councilor
thank you chair
um I'm aware of the late editions that's
been circulated and um I think that's to
be to be welcome I'd already prepared my
written submission
um which I think supplements the changes
of Vice Versa but there may be some
slight unnecessary duplication which
which I'll I'll apologize for
um so although I'm technically speaking
against the application I'm not against
it in totality but I'm supporting the
residents of Warwick Road South in their
submission primary against the
construction access being on Warwick
Road South
also certain details about the
application and their request for a
section 106 contribution to improve the
cycling pedestrian walkway to deliver
active travel for the school users and
The Wider community
for the record I support the
Redevelopment of the school which will
make a significant contribution to the
send provision in the area
also for the record I understand link
governor for one of the primary schools
in the area and I understand the
difficulties around this critical area
of Education
and primarily against the using Warwick
Road South as a construction axis for
the following reasons
the help and safety of residents of
Warwick Road South due to the
unnecessary movement of construction
traffic
causing diesel fumes and dust in close
proximity to the houses
Warwick Rose South and the passageway at
the end is part of a national cycle and
walkway route so there will be an
increased risk to Walkers and cyclists
using it not to mention residents
Warwick Road South is too narrow to
facilitate the Turning of large
construction vehicles on a street
with constantly parked cars due to the
lack of off-street parking and the Anson
Hilda C of E Primary School at the end
concern over the Safety and Security of
a mature Silver Birch Tree close to the
proximity of the highway and proposed
construction traffic entrance
there is also concern over the existing
Road surface which is in an already
pretty poor State and the constant use
of heavy construction traffic over over
a three-year period
I know this aspects of planning the
residents have made some wider points
about the application as referred to in
their submission email which is in the
pack
I will highlight some of the points but
that they make though their submission
gives gives more detail on this
The Pavilion building is forward of the
current building line so does not
project a uniform line on the street
scene
it also cuts down on the amount of green
space and is visually overbearing
the Green Space opposite will be
replaced with tarmac and less additional
planting is undertaken to displace this
there is a shortage of green space in
the area and I'm aware of other
applications in the area that have been
refused for proposing to replace a grass
area with tarmac
intention till I took the school during
Darkness hours will be intrusive on
residents and I refer to the residents
submission for more detail on this there
may be need to impose conditions to
alleviate this problem
on the section 106 request cycling and
walking at the end of Warwick Rose South
is a passageway which forms part of the
national cycling and walking Network
connected connecting the Midlands with
Preston
I am supporting in the residents in
their request for a section 106
contribution
to improve this and bring it up to the
current standard proactive travel
including better lighting
I wish to point to the submission of the
resident of 209 Oswald Road it was a
professional in this field and is giving
the benefit of his Professional
Knowledge in a personal capacity
this section of the route is substandard
and does not allow for users to pass in
both directions
requiring cyclists to Dismount the
report recognizes there would be a wider
Community benefit but says this cannot
be attached to directly to the
application
no doubt there could be pupils with
complex needs it could be wheelchair
users who would benefit from from this
The Proposal does include cycle parking
for 30 bikes and it's probable some of
these would be using the alleyway into
Manchester
it should be possible for the planning
to liaise with the highways Engineers to
see if there's any possibility of
getting any benefit from the greater
Manchester active travel initiative
foreign
thank you
uh Mr Hughes and Mr Roberts in the
audience
thank you you'll get three minutes
between you how are you how you wish to
spend it up is is
thank you
[Music]
okay
thank you chair The Replacements of
Saint John biani School is required
because the existing school is in poor
physical condition and consists of
buildings that are now beyond their
purpose one such building is already
close to pupils and is deemed unsuitable
for continued use the existing school is
therefore unable to develop deliver all
of the high quality facilities required
to meet the specialist needs of its
pupils the replacement school is net
zero carbon in operation and they'll be
funded through the first wave of the Fe
funding within the government School
rebuilding project
the development will not only provide a
vast Improvement in the level of
available facilities for pupils but in
addition the proposals will also provide
a significant long-term Improvement for
residents with the inclusion of a
proposed new internal access road and
traffic management system within the
site which will significantly reduce the
need for vehicles to queue on ryobank
road or local side roads once the
development's complete the applicant has
worked with officers to address any
issues that have Arisen during the
application and has confirmed as
confirmed within the officer's reporter
committee there are no technical matters
or reasons why the application should be
refused and planning terms the
development is acceptable in all
respects and great weight must be given
to the need to expand on alter schools
and to ensure that sufficient choice of
school places is available to meet the
needs of existing in new communities as
required by paragraph 95 of the mpbf I
therefore trust you'll be able to
support your office of recommendation
and support the proposal
School must remain operational after
construction works are being undertaken
and as such a phased approach to the
construction is necessary
as a result of this phasing we are
required to use Warwick Road South to
access the site in order to construct
the new school building adjacent
Pavilion there is no viable alternative
access to this phase of the works we end
the process of formulating a
construction management plan in
conjunction in conjunction with the
school St Hilda school and the highway
Authority
this will set out the safest possible
method of vehicles accessing and egress
in the site
and the means by which the impacts of
the construction activities on the
neighbors will be minimized
specific elements of this plan will
include
detailed Logistics plan including
sweatpath analysis
a dedicated neighbor liaison manager and
their contact details
a 24-hour emergency contact number a
dedicated trained traffic manager who
will be used to proactively manage
construction traffic movements on and
around Warwick Road South
an electronic delivery booking system to
ensure deliveries are assigned to a
specific slot to avoid congestion
systems are measures to be put in place
to protect cyclists and pedestrians
measures to be taken to reduce the
impact on the site on the local street
parking
a measures to be implemented in order to
control the emission of dirt dust and
noise during the works
we take the impact of our works on the
neighbors School users and public
extremely seriously
their safety is only one priority when
planning and undertaking the
construction phase of these works
thank you okay thank you
before I open this up to members could I
just ask for some
um
some comments on the two points which I
think I picked out of what the what the
applicant said one was around the
traffic management plan for the
construction works and When I Look to
You um for that and also I keep coming
to report the section 106 reference
because miss those make some reference
to that
okay thank you so now Mr Evans all about
the the traffic management plan
uh thank you chair um in terms of the
traffic management plan has been
mentioned um there's still some work to
do on that particular item in that
in terms of the being able to actually
access it down uh Warwick Road South
um so there's still some work to do but
the condition
um addresses those those points which
haven't actually been submitted yet
um I guess from a highway perspective
it's a little disappointing that some of
the skills we've had recently we've been
and sorted and even changed the style of
of the design of the school so that
where we've had difficulties in getting
access we've actually changed the design
so from a highway perspective and we
feel comfortable that the condition
addresses the concerns allows us to
control what actually happens on the on
the on the site but it would have been
nice to have
had the opportunity to work that through
during the application stage but that
hasn't actually achieved and as I say
some of the skills the temp for more
infant skill we actually change the
design because it couldn't actually get
into the site
and you know you have to work within
what you've got and the assumptions of
you know
dislodging
um residents and not taking account of
that those those issues do need to be
overcome but the condition in which is
particularly the one which has been
revised
allows us to address those points going
forward as opposed to being able to give
you all the answers tonight okay the
point is there will be conversations
taking place above the developers to
address their concerns okay thank you
and just in terms of the um
section 106 agreement from a highway
perspective
um I do recognize what um the residents
have asked asking for and possibly if it
had been an ordinary school it probably
would have been Justified justifiable
but given the school is a special school
a large proportion of the children come
in to the school by many Boswell or
actual transport
so for us to be able to justify we
believe it needs to meet the tests and
unfortunately as much as we would like
to
um and we did explore the the option
um but given the way the the children
come into the school
it would be very difficult for us to say
that it's necessary to make the
development acceptable and therefore we
don't believe the taxi meets the tests
so it's something we don't think we
could support or ask
um well at least so sorry
Afghanistan yeah the point the point
you're making is it's and um because
it's a special needs school is that to
be able to attire section 106 agreement
on cycle access to that you need to
demonstrate that lots of people going to
the school why indeed okay all right
thank you
which any members to speak
I think so sorry sir sorry
thank you and yeah just I'll just make
two quick points
um on the um construction management
plan just to say that that is a prior to
commencement
um condition so all of that needs to be
agreed and with the local highways
Authority and the local planning
Authority before they can even start any
works on site so we've got full control
over insuring that that is appropriate
and addresses the concerns and um
creates the correct environment for the
construction and for the local residents
before work start on site then on to the
um section 106
um point and the report kind of does set
this out quite clearly in in paragraph
96 to 99 but for us to require
um a contribution that there needs to be
some some harm and and presently we
don't believe that there will be any
harm to the cycle route or to the to the
alleyway as a result of of this
development and the the still one two
two tests which are
um necessary to make the development
acceptable and directly related to the
development
um aren't passed by this application
um as as Jeff rightly said most of the
pupils access the site by minibus and
they would the the the cycle route
wouldn't experience any harm or undue
impact as a result of this development
so officers can made the conclusions
that any contribution towards
improvements wouldn't be necessary to
make this development acceptable and
planning teams nor directly related
all right thank you Miss loves well
that's remember contribution you
counteract them I think other people
indicated
thank you chair
um clearly there are real concerns from
residents about
this application and I've listened very
carefully to what have has been said
however
um I think
this is a much needed Sen school to
replace the very old and tired building
that is there at this moment in in time
which is not fit for purpose and I think
all the relevant
planning issues which have been raised
um have been answered and addressed
in person and in the report and so
as far as I'm concerned
this the school
sen children deserve a modern up-to-date
School comprising
of all the facilities that they actually
need to to have a good learning
experience so I will actually move that
we accept
um the recommendations
thank you chair uh Council councilor
baba Sorry
thank you chair
um I agree with your Contracting and if
I could also mention that this proposed
development is a direct reflection of
you know the government School
rebuilding program you know announced in
2020 we can see the building is in a
poor condition and um this new
development will obviously give you know
the children a much needed new building
and then
um thanks to Sarah she's highlighted so
the concerns which I had we can see
that's been addressed in paragraph 17
and 18 which basically gives us you know
that peace of mind that they won't move
an inch without the prior approval and
satisfaction of the offices thank you
thank you councilor Council accordingly
uh thank you chair
um I really welcome this school
um I have
one point to make I don't think it's big
enough it's retaining the existing
capacity and not increasing it I think I
don't understand that these schools are
really in demand at the moment surely it
should be expanded at the same time
um I don't think there's anything I can
do about that but it should have been
and it's woeful of the DFE not to be
thinking of that
in terms of the psychopath I totally get
what planning is saying I totally don't
get what highways were saying for
because you were talking about
um whether School users would use this
and I I thought we were straying Goods
with slightly tricky area there because
there's lots of evidence that actually
all children need to be active and um
and now so I totally get
having said that this is the one
opportunity to expand that and I know I
will I wouldn't even think of doing a
106 even if I could because that's
imposing a cost on the school and I
don't given that I think the school
should be bigger and last thing I want
to do
is taking money away from the school so
I wouldn't even be doing it from there
but the developer has any spare time
while they're doing it and can nudge the
fence a little bit or whatever then I
would truly welcome it because it is it
is the the best route between Old
Trafford and Manchester that avoids
roads
and it is highly and I can remember
um a planning officer here who was
really keen on that particular route
um
but um she yeah so I I I'm I'm totally
in support and happy to second or
whatever
thank you councilor Council Proctor
thank you Chad
again totally support this it's
brilliant we have to have schools fit
for purpose for all children
especially for our more vulnerable
children
my question though is about the state of
Warwick Road South and what it's going
to look like after lots and lots of
construction vehicles have gone up and
down it there's already cracks in the
road
the surface is pitted and in poor
condition now
and
I think the developer should
be heavily encouraged to consider the
state of the road now and when they're
finished
and if significant damage has been done
to the surface of that road I think the
developers should contribute to having
it fixed because it will be their
vehicles that of course the damage thank
you
I'll ask an opinion of the officers on
that to see if that's
thank you in the um additional
information report in the updated
condition we've actually required them
to provide a pre-commencement for
photographic Highway dilapidation survey
and a post-construction photographic
Highway dilapidation survey so we can
see what it's like before they start and
then after they start and then Jeff
might be able to answer that question
about compensation for
um the impact on the highway through the
highways act I don't know if that's how
that works
[Music]
yeah and in terms of um
if the if there's recognized damage and
we can identify where it's actually come
from hence these surveys
then under the highways act there are um
we can't sort of notice on them to
correct that defect yes brilliant thank
you both
uh councilmanis
oh fantastic well done well well done
councilor Hassan
oh thank you sir
I fully supported the my previous
speakers I said just uh
my question has already been unserved by
the by Jeffrey uh the
it is a sentence goal it is not a high
school or a primary school is going to
be built it's a special school for the
special children and and the children
are coming not everyone every child is
coming with parents no it is they are
coming all together in a group
this is number one and and I I fully
support this application and and I
second to all my previous the only one
question is we already working on this
as
um
regarding uh walk to school so there's
nothing rounds about back to school this
is a special education school so there
is no point to to object or to reject
this application so I fully support this
okay thank you thank you counselor so
it's been moved and seconded that we
support this in lab lost recommendation
always my favorite could indicate
thank you
so we voted to approve that in line with
officer recommendation so moving on to
the next items when the agenda is
uh 43 the Crescent flixton uh Mr
moorehouse we give the introduction
introduction on this uh can be found on
page 192 of your pack
okay
um
thank you chair the this application
seeks retrospective planning permission
for the change of use from a dwelling
house use class C3
to a small to medium HMO that is three
to six residents use class C4
with a love conversion and other
external alterations
objections have been received from the
occupiers of 16 nearby properties
these relate primarily to the principle
of an HMO and the impact of the pros
development on the residential immunity
of neighbors and future occupants
design ecology drainage waste parking
provision and Highway Safety
um just looking at the the plans on the
screen you can see that the site is so
many Touched property on the western
side of the crescent
the external alterations comprise two
reeflights on the front elevation
and soil pipes on the side and rear
elevations
and the layout it was originally a three
bed property there are now four ensuite
bedrooms one on the ground floor
two on the first floor and one in the
Loft conversion
and there's a communal kitchen and
living space on the ground floor
and there's also a cycle store and Bin
stories proposed in the rear Garden
thank you
relevant to the assessment of The
Proposal is spd6
houses in multiple occupation which was
adopted by the council in March 2018.
the purpose of this guidance is to
prevent an excessive concentration of
hmos in one area
and encourage a more even distribution
across the borough
it is not intended to prevent the
creation of hmos entirely
in relation to the tests in spd6
the development would comply with the
guidance and would not result in an
excessive concentration of hmos in this
area
and therefore the use is considered to
be acceptable in principle subject to
the consideration of detailed issues
officers consider the proposal would not
be outkeeping with the residential
nature of the area and would not harm
the living conditions of the occupiers
of neighboring properties with regard to
noise and disturbance privacy or any
other issue
the development would also provide an
acceptable standard of accommodation for
existing and future occupants of the HMO
officers also consider the disposal
would be acceptable in terms of impact
on highway safety and parking provisions
and given given that there is no
increase in parking requirements having
regard to the council's adopted spd3
parking standards
and the lha has raised no objections
the scheme would also be acceptable in
terms of visual immunity bin storage
ecology and drainage
The Proposal makes a small contribution
in terms of broadening the range of
housing accommodation available within
the borough and would not Resort in any
adverse impacts that was significantly
or demonstrably outweigh the benefits of
granting planning permission
as such the development calls with
policies in the core strategy including
policy L7
spd6 and the mppf and is recommended for
approval subject conditions thank you
chair
thank you Mr moorhouse we have a written
statement first from Tom Simpson one of
the neighbors that'll be read by lesbian
yourself
have you got the drill by now you'll get
three minutes from when you start to
speak thank you very much uh thank you
for granting me time to speak for you
today uh together with my wife and
lastly our son I have lived at 35th
Crescent since January 2021. before I
developed my objections in further
detail I just want to highlight certain
provisions of policy L7 of the core
strategy in particular which frame my
objections so to quote a development
must incorporate vehicular access and
egress having regard to need for Highway
Safety provide sufficient off-street car
parking maneuvering and operational
space provide appropriate provision of
and access to wage recycling facilities
not Prejudice immunity the future
occupies development and our occupants
of adjacent Properties by reasons of
overbearing intrusion or noise so
parking and Highway Safety I reject in
the strongest terms the statement in the
planning recommendation that to quote
there is no increased demand for parking
provision that is plainly untrue when
there could be potentially six residents
within the HMO and at least four based
on the advertised lettings today to
confirm no other family on the street
has more than two cars with most having
just the one however the HMO will
potentially lead to four and even up to
six cars requiring spaces not to mention
visitors and guests as a recommendation
points out there is no provision for
off-road parking on the street to
accommodate these cars even before the
HMO was converted without planning
permission parking has been an issue on
the street for example at weekends my
wife and I often can't park anywhere
near our house nor on nearby Windsor
Avenue sometimes having to park 300
meters away because of the Overflow of
parking which makes it incredibly
difficult when for example returning
from their weekly Shop with a
two-year-old in the car in addition in
the first eight months or so I live in
our pro at our property our car was
taken off the road twice after being hit
when stationary parked outside our house
given a limited room for maneuvering and
I refer you back to the L7 core strategy
in terms of maneuvering once by Nova
accidentally scraping and dent in the
side and second by a hit and run
delivery driver
particularly since 43 has been used as a
HMO the Overflow of parking means people
often bigger cars or Vans have taken to
parking on the street corners next to
Windsor Avenue this has made it
incredibly dangerous leaving the street
particularly given Winter Avenue is used
as a through role to get to flixon
Junior school and many parents parking
on the street use a nearby Alleyway to
get to the school I myself are very
nearly hit a school child on a bike when
turning right out of the road as my as
my view was completely blocked by a van
parked in the corner
finally we have already had the waste
management team a traffic Council
refused to empty our bins because they
can't fit down the street due to the
parking situation as far as I'm aware
this has only occurred since the use of
the property as a HMR
I understand the planning committee may
not have seen the content of all 16
objections raised by the residents
during the planning consultation phase
however it must be noted that the
resident who lives directly adjacent to
the HMO has already made one noise
complaint it being noted that she had
not previously ever made such a
complaint when it was being used as a
family home
I would urge the plan committee to take
the abundance account and in line with
the NP npf I do think that the adverse
impacts of allowing this HMO license was
significantly demonstrably outweigh the
benefits and final point we have taken a
three-bedroom house out of the housing
market
that's the final point and we've heard
today about the shortage of family
houses in the area thank you very much
okay thank you Mr Simpson there Council
Thomas if you care to approach the
microphone
again you'll get five minutes as a ward
counselor for when you start to speak
thank you Council how long to five
minutes counselor
thank you chair for the opportunity to
support the existing residents already
impacted innovatively by this aged
retrospective application
as per submissions the resident of
residents in the Crescent this HMO has
been used for several months prior to
this application and it's just thought
that the planning application actually
arose from the intervention of the
former leader of the council who was
contacted by residents asking what they
could do after being impacted by the
tenants of this HMO without planning
permission despite the applicant already
having at least one HMO in Trafford
we now have an application that damages
residential immunity and environmental
immunity this by way of noise nuisance
traffic issues on a residential
cul-de-sac where families with children
reside and on a wider scope parking
issues for the residents in nearby
already overloaded streets there are
already at least two cars associated
with the property reported to the
compliance officer by residents despite
the agent stating that no vehicles were
at the property this has already
impacted on the collection of waste from
April 20 2022 to confirm through
non-access of collection Vehicles due to
pay Vehicles Parts on pavement and the
street corner there have been incidents
also have bins not being collected at
the property through cross-contamination
and complaints into the council despite
what the additional information says of
noise levels at the property in the
early hours of the morning causing
continue on and off of the security
lights certainly impacting on
residential immunity the traffic
evaluation undertaken by the applicant's
own company
is at best a utopian View and yet the
local highways Authority has not
commented on the massive issues logged
by residents of the Crescent Windsor
Avenue and White Lake Avenue regarding
the unending issues with parking on all
these rows for many many many years this
application has only been advertised
also on a single lamp post outside the
HMO residents on Windsor and White Lake
Avenue will be completely unaware of
this advertisement is not sufficient the
survey that They carried out expresses a
view that these roads are not in
Marlborough Road uh just around the
corner could well accommodate the excess
parking need I've spoken to and know
personally residents on these roads and
they tell me that you most definitely
cannot there's no mention of these
surrounding roads where children walk to
and from flixton primary school or the
effects of even more pavement parking
will have on the impact on road safety
caused by this application as illustated
by the pictures provided by email to the
members of this committee
no noting of the increase in vehicles of
school time nor on the effect of
immunity of children using what we all
did in our youth
quiet low-speed call attack as an area
to play on cycles and scooters to learn
the value of road signs in a safe way
I'd like to draw the committee's
attention to the following spd5
paragraphs the primary concern of the
council's residential parking standards
in this respect is therefore to protect
on-street amenities from inappropriate
parking to ensure that residential
streets remain functional for all users
the picture used on by the council to
illustrate this is a mirror image of the
vehicle parts on the corner in the
pictures you saw
for residential development car parking
below the maximum standard will only be
allowed where there is no adverse impact
on ensuite parking arising from the
development this may be because one or
more of the following criteria met one
there is sufficient capacity of ensuite
parking without detrimentally affecting
the safety and convenience of all other
residents and occupiers and Road users
there isn't and there is an effect to
the development meets other meets other
planning objectives and would not set on
accidentally worsen the parking
situation it's seriously worsens it the
party wall at number 41 has four
bedrooms and the communal dining kitchen
adjacent there will be no relief in any
room in number 41 whether that be from
the TV playing music playing or simply
the sound of showering vastly different
to our standard family occupancy which
would be expected to have a focus on a
family living room an occasional bedroom
use
the HMO conditions will have an impact
on the future sale of 41 thus impacting
negatively on the residents to conclude
there has always been odd already being
destruction to the neighbors immediately
Nest this HMO by way of noise harm the
parking has
interrupted waste collections as stated
to Amy and I quote as due to excessive
parking on Pavements and street corners
again April the 22nd was the first
instance of this after the 80 mile was
opened potentially there are two cars
potentially there are two on or two to
four more Vehicles could be uh resident
of the property depending on the unknown
needs of potential future residents
to finish I think that the above gives
solid grounds for refusal of this
application thank you committee
uh thank you councilor is Mr Taylor the
audience
[Music]
thank you
uh you will get three minutes from when
you press the button on your microphone
thank you Mr Taylor
good evening committee my name is Ralph
Taylor of Paul bottle Associates the
buying consultants for this application
and I'm representing the applicant Jason
McKnight I'm speaking to requests that
members back their officer's
recommendation and support this
application
firstly I want to acknowledge that the
application is retrospective as the
applicant generally didn't realize that
pie permission was required to use the
properties four-person HTML
indeed this development would have been
permitted development except for the
introduction of the article 4 Direction
related to UA 92.
following extensive investment and
refurbishment the property now provides
a high quality of accommodation for four
residents the residents are
professionals who work at nearby
Trafford General Hospital
all rooms are ensuite in single
occupancy although they comfortably
exceed the 10.2 square meter size
standard for double occupancy
there is also a shared kitchen living
space and a good sized Garden
the council's housing standards
consultation of endorsed development and
have confirmed the property is finished
to a very high standard of accommodation
for shared residents soundproofing has
been installed throughout the property
including to the party wall which is in
excess of building regulation
requirements as confirmed in the
officer's report the application occurs
with the policy tests set out in the HMO
SPD and will not lead to a nerve
concentration of hmos within the area
the application is supported by the
local highways Authority a parking
survey has demonstrated that there is
availability for on-street parking in
the locality which reflects the existing
situation
it is noted that none of the residents
own a car while car ownership is
typically less likely for HMO residents
a secure and covered cycle store has
been provided in the rear Garden of
property
within the committee report issues
around Waste Management were highlighted
and as a result the applicant has been
proactive remaining residents of their
responsibilities and installing clear
signage to prevent any misunderstanding
it also has an arrangement with a
third-party company a premier Waste
Services who are able to promptly
collect waste if Council collections are
missed for any reason or any additional
collections are necessary
it's appreciated the other issues have
been raised by objectives and we
consider that these have been
appropriately responded to by officers
within the committee report
to conclude the application is supported
by Council applying officers and no
objections have been received from the
HMO officer the local Highway Authority
environmental health or any other
Council departments the property has
been converted to a high quality HMO
accommodation to meet the needs of young
doctors nurses and other professionals
with nearby air traffic General
or relevant planning matters have been
carefully addressed within the planning
application submission and is confirmed
the development is in accordance with
national and local planning policy on
this basis we respectfully request the
members support their office
recommendation and Grant my permission
thank you
uh thank you Mr Taylor uh would be able
to turn this today to get some comments
on the uh the issues around residential
immunity in terms of noise and also I'd
be really interested to know if uh some
comments on the consultation that was
carried out and after that Mr Robinson
we could go to you some comments on the
the traffic issues which have been
raised Mr day
absolutely
um so yeah in terms of you you want to
do specific comments on noise impacts um
I mean obviously
um we've consulted the council's
nuisance
um section they've raised no objections
on that basis
um and really there's no reason to
anticipate that there would be any
significantly greater noise impacts as a
result of this type of use compared with
a residential property which could be
occupied by um
a large family
um that um that was reflected in a
recent appeal decision that we had
relating to a property at mossvale road
which was refused by committee and and
that was the inspector's conclusions in
terms of that application
um and that was for a larger HMO of six
to eight bedrooms so
in regard to the nuisance comments we
don't feel there's any um any reason to
anticipate any significant noise issues
with this application
um
regarding the the consultation
um the the consultation that's been
carried out on the application complies
with statutory requirements and it
complies with the statements with with
the council's statement of community
involvement it would be it's entirely
normal
for one
um slight notice to be put up for a
development of this nature and and for
immediate neighbors to be consulted and
it would would certainly not be
normal to consult um residents on other
streets other than properties that
actually back on to the site directly
um
in terms of another a number of other
points that have been raised um it's
been um there's been a comment that
there's been
a noise complaint made about this
property we've we've checked with our
environmental health colleagues and they
have no record of any noise complaint in
relation to this property
um
in terms of other issues in terms of the
parking we obviously appreciate that
the parking situation is difficult
that's a pre-existing situation that was
there before this use
um took place
um it's it's a it's a common situation
across the streets across the borough
and in fact across cities all over the
country the the the comments that have
been made by neighbors could equally be
applied to the street that I live on
um
in terms of our parking standards
there's a neutral impact the parking
requirement for this development is for
two cars the parking requirement for the
existing uses for two cars there is no
off street parking provision for this
dwelling there's no street parking
provision for the existing use so that
the impacts in terms of that is neutral
um even if it were considered that that
you know even if there were four cars
associated with the development one for
each bedroom
um that would only be two additional
parking car cars parking on the street
above that um that standard and um you
know it couldn't be demonstrated that
two additional cars would have a
significant additional impact on on
parking on the parking issues
um there's no no there's no evidence to
link
this use with
um the fact that the waste management
um on one occasion have not delivered on
the street
um I've not I've not collected bins on
the street because you just pause there
baby I can hear somebody comments from
the public Gallery could you could you
please not you get your contribution
when you come to the microphone after
that it's a debate amongst the committee
and the uh the council officers thank
you apologies Mr Davey carry on yeah so
yeah and final Point really that um
the cross-contamination of waste is not
an issue that we could consider as part
of the material considerations in in the
planning application
okay thank you I think we've covered the
highways from Mr um Mr donations from
the job Mr evidence all I would like to
do is to reiterate uh Mr dice comments
and that we apply spd3 the maximum is
two spaces and that's the same as they
existing and therefore we don't see
there's a an opportunity to raise an
objection or be there is an issue
locally with parking boots it's equal
unfortunately thank you Mr Evans any
member wish to speak
[Music]
it's really the the point about
the planning application
um that was on Moss Bale Road
um you know I remember that one because
it's uh in my world and
it was I said
and
um
and you know I argued quite strongly
that it shouldn't be
um passed
um and we we did reject it
um as the officer has said uh and
um what happened from there was that
they appealed
um and
um
uh rejected
the council opinion on that
and I assume that it does cost a certain
amount of money when that happens
I'm not convinced that this you know if
if this application we passed it I think
the same thing would probably happen
because if the president within the area
so
you know I I
personally can't afford it just for that
reason
you can't sorry I I can't support the
recommendations
okay no I can't support the lessons
in my face I'm thinking thinking is it
me counselor is it me okay no it's
definitely me thank you councilor Upton
uh councilor Evans
thank you chair
um
I find this particularly worrying
actually and I really would like to not
support the recommendation and
I I consider if we were considering this
as an application as opposed to a
retrospective application I don't think
it would actually have reached us I
think the officers would have advised
against it
I know you shake I I just I just we are
Trafford is full of these houses so many
tax properties small white Lake uh
Windsor Marlborough the Crescent they're
tiny roads and they are pretty much at
capacity
we're adding effectively three
households here and it's quite worrying
the fact that we can't
or we're afraid to turn it down really
concerns me I I suspect we will end up
passing this because we've we've got a
precedent perhaps on mossdale road
although I do think mossdale road is a
totally different Road alongside this
alongside the motorway isn't it it is
alongside the motor it's a different
Road altogether
um
I think we might end up passing it but I
really I think we need to look at this
and perhaps consider within our planning
department how we look at a tsunami of
these nice little learner for some
people it worries me and it doesn't get
me to a point where I'm gonna I'd love
to propose rejecting this I think we
need to be brave and perhaps reject it
and but I'll sit on the fence for the
moment and perhaps there's some other
comments I think it's worrying with all
the semis we've got all over the place
yes uh Miss Coney some comments
um
I do need to challenge the
um the point you made counselor that
officers would have uh sought to refuse
this application if it had come and not
being retrospective it is a principle of
the planning system which this committee
is is aware of that we do not treat
retrospective applications in any
different way to to retreat normal
applications if this has been put before
us as a proposal the same recommendation
would be in front of you this this
evening there would be no change in that
um the other thing is that in terms of
control we do have the control we have
an SPD
um this would otherwise be permitted
development we wanted additional
controls but through the article 4 but
at that point we've imposed those
controls we've adopted an SPD and said
this is the control we're going to have
over this this use because we want it to
have planning permission so we can't
shouldn't really Step Beyond that so if
it complies with the SPD we should be
approving it because otherwise it would
be permitted development beyond that can
troll thank you
yeah thank you Miss Coley Council
minutes
thank you chair
um whilst I have a huge amount of
Sympathy for the residents that live on
the crescent and I can understand the
whole it's a it's a small Road it's very
small Road
um the thing is that when you have a
hospital
um and you have staff obviously the
staff at the hospital nearby the nearby
roads do quite it's not uncommon shall
we say to have houses where you have
um
a few people living there that work in
the hospital this is a normal thing I
mean I I work a hospital in Manchester
it's the same situation there
that's what has
um in addition the fact that it's a
student area too so what I'd say is that
whilst this is
um you know I'm I'm sympathetic to the
residents the trouble is that you do
need you do need homes for people that
are working in the hospital when they
first at least when they first start out
living in a home with other people
shared accommodation is a normal thing
um so I think that given that you know
the idea is just to quite rightfully to
share the mouth and not have them in
concentrated quite in one little road
and you have them on different roads I
think that's that's a way to approach it
um whilst it's not high you know no one
wants to live on a street with with such
houses they are necessary thing and I
will be proposing that we support
office's recommendation and Grant this
thank you
thank you councilor Council accordingly
like many others I live on a a road that
is
um actually narrower than this one and
we have HMS hmos usually
admittedly to the houses are smaller so
they don't they don't actually come to
planning
um
the way I don't like hmos I love the
people that live on our road and I love
the people that live in the hmos and I I
do
so those two things need to be kept
separate
we have a housing problem of 30 years of
mismanaging and hmos are the results of
that housing crisis that we have been
built ourselves I don't like them
but they are necessary people need homes
um
in terms of the the the the bin
collection I totally accept we we have
problems
regularly I know
um people colleagues of mine will know
that I've been chasing the um uh seven
year review so make sure that it doesn't
make things worse for roads like
hours in the Crescent where the
incentive to Amy to do the maximum
number of collections on the day doesn't
detract from collecting difficult
streets and this will will be a
difficult stream not as difficult as
mine but it will be a difficult Street
the more hmos you have on it because
you're adding to the amount of cars
those cars are getting bigger uh the bin
wagons are getting bigger
and we've got a problem
um so if people want that just you
know it really creates a problem but I I
really worry about
um actually the way we're almost talking
down the inhabitants of an HMO and I
don't think we should be doing that
um
the HMO
I I'm happy to Second The Proposal
um I'm happy that we we've got the right
procedures in place but I would like us
to build more houses
uh thank you Council only the member
wishing to speak
Council Proctor thank you chair this is
going to sound really silly I apologize
for this I've just discovered by looking
on Google Earth as opposed to street
view that I live five houses away I need
to recuse myself
oh thank you counselor
counteractively
thank you
um
I respect
the decision that the bank officers have
made I completely understand where
they've come from with that
however I do feel
um
negative towards uh hmos in general
and the addition to the housing stock
with these hmos seem fairly
insignificant
When taking into account the um
highly negative impact that they can
have on existing local residents
um for me the Crescent is a very small
Road
I feel that these properties have been
built to house families
and for me I'd like to support family
life and people who wish to have family
home
I must be boring people
um
so yeah there is a reduction in a number
of family houses and we should support
the the the number of family houses that
we have for residents
with regards to the parking issue
um it has been said that the HMO
residents don't have cars even if this
is true shots and we don't necessarily
know that for the long term there's no
guarantees there and I know myself from
living on a busy world with parking it
is it does have a really detrimental
impact on your quality of life and when
you consider the parking
um issues there
um
I do feel that there may be some damage
to residential immunity I think the
points raised by the neighbor Tom
Simpson were relatively valid
um and yeah so on that basis I would be
um
sadly going against the the the offices
and looking to refuse this supplication
thank you yeah thank you thank you
counselor I think I can feel the mood of
the committee is is split on this one I
think
and we don't like hmos but they are what
they are and the the significance of HMO
is a failure of housing policy as
Council accordingly says where we find
ourselves in this position we're also in
the position of the the uh the officers
report which says that we uh it's it's
moving towards accepting this but I have
tremendous tremendous sympathy with the
residents on on the Crescent tremendous
empathy and I'm worried as if there's
some and if I could just check this with
the officers to see if this is a
possibility
now what I had in mind by not
technically be possible
um so and I am absolutely torn on this
so if we move to the boat and this being
proposed and seconded that we accept
this and it's in its current format all
those in favor
right and all those against
uh then that is that is carried along
with officer recommendation before we
move on to the next item can we just
take a five minute break there come back
at just after 10 past by that clock at
the end there
uh if we can now reconvene we now move
on to
um Masonic Hall and police station at
Town Road in sale
uh it's on page one of the pack and Mr
Pearson will give the introduction thank
you Mr Pearson
[Music]
thank you chair this application relates
to the site of the form of sail Masonic
Hall and sale police station which is
situated on Tatton Road and Tatton Place
partly within the boundary of sail tone
Center
the application proposes the demolition
of the existing Masonic Hall and the
erection of a three-story building and
the conversion of the former police
station to provide a total of 20
apartments and 10 houses across the site
all of the proposed apartments and
houses will be affordable shared
ownership units
the principle of the development is
considered to be acceptable
the existing buildings are considered to
be non-designated Heritage assets
whilst the demolition of the existing
Masonic Hall would harm its significance
the significance is considered to be low
it's considered the overall harm of the
proposed development would be moderate
taking into account proposed building
and the proposed alterations to the
former police station
the development does not include the
provision of any car parking
the applicant sought to address the
shortfall through a review and extension
of the timing of parking restrictions on
the residential streets close to the
application site
and whilst this approach is accepted by
officers in terms of limiting harm to
existing residents it cannot address the
issue of the absence of accessible car
parking provision
the application includes the provision
of 30 secure cycle parking spaces within
the landscape Garden to the east of the
site
scale Mustang design and appearance of
the proposed development is considered
to be acceptable
will provide an attractive outlook for
most neighboring residents and generally
have a less overbearing impact and a
reduced level of overshadowing on most
of the neighboring properties on Chapel
Road and the existing bit and the
existing building
some adverse impacts have been
identified including that the
development would result in a reduction
in privacy to some existing residents on
Tatton Road and Chapel Road to the east
some generally negligible harm would
also arise to non-designated Heritage
assets
that would also be a shortfall in the
provision of amenity space for future
residents against the recommendations in
spd1
the benefits of the development
including the provision of 30 shared
ownership properties in a highly
sustainable location the contribution it
would make towards addressing the
council's identified housing land Supply
shortfall and the regenerative benefits
of the scheme overall
the scheme would comply with a
development plan when taken as a whole
13 letters of support and one letter of
objection were received in relation to
the originally submitted plans
following a re-consultation subsequent
to the submission of those amended plans
one letter of support one letter of
objection and one letter with mixed
comments have been received from
neighboring residents
the Tilted balance in mppf paragraph 11
is engaged it's considered that the
adverse impacts are granting permission
would not significantly and demonstrably
outweigh the benefits of doing so
the applications therefore recommended
for approval with conditions subject to
the completion of the section 106 legal
agreement securing Financial
contributions for a review of the
existing permit parking area on
surrounding streets on a full Financial
contribution towards education provision
the additional information report
includes additional comments from a
neighbor and the Civic Society a
revision to the Landscaping condition
and additional conditions relating to
drainage and want to enable the planning
authority to consider the potential for
salvaging elements of interest from the
original building and incorporating
those into the new building
in addition to that if I may I would
suggest if members of minded to approve
the application want further condition
and that would be to require a
methodology to to be submitted for the
conversion of the police station thank
you chair
thank you Mr Pearson is uh Sammy K top
in the audience
as before you will get three minutes
once you press the start button on the
microphone
sorry second no no
no it's a nice idea that would know
thank you very much thank you for
offering me the opportunity to address
this community my name is Sami katube I
am the resident and the owner of 61
Chapel Road which is behind this new
development uh I'm probably here not as
an individual also I share some uh as a
representing for the rest of the
Neighbors which is having their concern
regarding this development
um we would like to express our strong
object uh opposition to this proposal
proposed development which based on
three three key issues for us firstly is
we are deeply concerned about not
providing any parking space associating
with this new development as you all
aware
Town Center already suffer from solution
parking residents like myself face
challenging in finding barking spots for
all for our vehicles and introducing a
new huge building with probably 100 of
residents and visitors without
sufficient parking Provisions would make
the problem much worse
sorry annual place an overwhelming
burden on our already crowded Street and
make it uh even unsafe we proposed
probably three point which is I agree
with the officer bringing some some more
uh resident only barking instead of from
8 till 18 to bring it to 24 hours and
seven days a week will probably help to
solve this issue
again also we we expect to have some
legal notes on the development to say
that there isn't not now or in future
we'll have the the ability to join this
uh resident parking scheme and in the
meantime also we expect to have at least
15 parking space with this development
to be uh to be sufficient for a resident
and visitors and some of them should be
for disabled people secondly also I
would like to drive your attention about
the alarming strain of this development
which would place in our essential
Services the additional of 20
appointment document and 10 houses with
over probably 100 residents which in a
very small area will overwhelm our
existing infrastructure placing a lot of
pressure on the service and the school
arounding it
lastly I wish to highlight the increase
of the height of the new developments
from the from the chopper road side
which we believe that
will affect our uh significantly our our
sunlight which reaching our rooms at in
the houses of 57 to 63 Chapel Road and I
believe that developers are trying to
push to the max with this development to
get too much from a very small space I
appreciate your attention to all of this
matter and I'm sure you will you'll make
the right decision for the best of our
community thank you
as Miss Lindsey clap Linda clap in the
audience
thank you you know by now you will get
three minutes from when you press the
microphone
thank you chair for allowing me to
address the committee this evening
clap and I'm speaking on my clients
Southway Housing Trust in respect to the
proposal before you
Southway is a leading provider of
affordable housing in South Manchester
with a strong commitment to addressing
housing needs Southway has been
delivering safe and secure homes for
over 15 years as I'm not not
organization their primary focus is on
providing affordable housing options to
individuals and families in the
community
we welcome your officer's recommendation
to approve the planning application at
Tatum Road the scheme in front of you
today is a product of a number of months
hard work in both the design team and
your planning officers to ensure that
all previous concerns raised have been
alleviated where possible
importantly the scheme has been
sympathetically designed to help
preserve and protect the important
historic attributes of the former police
station we have worked proactively with
your officers throughout the application
process to ensure that the scheme
presented to you today provides for a
development which responds to its
surroundings particularly given the
site's constraints and is of an
exceptionally high quality design
since 2020 the scheme has been amended
to reduce the height from four to three
stories and reduce the proposed building
footprint to create outdoor immunity
space for residents furthermore all
homes now fully comply with the
government's nationally described space
standards
the team has explored the potential to
provide parking on site but following
safety concerns raised by the local
high-res Authority which could not be
overcome this will unfortunately removed
from the scheme
nevertheless the site is highly
accessible on foot and Via a range of
public transport modes particularly
given its short walking distance to sail
town center and the tram stop The
Proposal also includes sufficient
opportunities for safe and secure
bicycle storage
importantly your highways officers raise
no objections to The Proposal
furthermore Southway has agreed to pay a
financial contribution for a review of
the existing residence permit parking
area on surrounding streets
the application is supported by a
sunlight and daylight assessment which
considers the proposed impact on the
existing neighboring properties and
Gardens and on the proposed new
dwellings
the assessment demonstrates that the
development would not result in an
unacceptable level of overshadowing
indeed all potential impacts on
residential immunity have been
thoroughly considered and officers have
concluded that overall the scheme
provide for a more attractive Outlook
when compared to the current reviews
we are delighted that we have the
support of local people during our
pre-application consultation process 73
of local people Express support 14
residents have written in support to the
council with only two objections
to conclude the scheme represents a
positive investment on a key Brownfield
site which has been designed to ensure
that is sympathetic to its surroundings
it will create a high quality scheme
which significantly improves the
Aesthetics of the surrounding area and
provides much needed affordable housing
in Trafford thank you for your time
today
again before I go to the members
um Mr Pearson could you make some
comments on the parking issues around
here
well as part of this game thank you
thank you uh councilor
um
yeah I mean
the problem here I mean the council has
an SPD spd3 which indicates that we'll
require wherever possible the
developments should be fully accessible
and usable by all sections of the
community
unfortunately the problem with this
scheme is that it's just not possible to
provide any parking at all
um
so
you know we've we've talked to the
highway Authority and and to the to the
applicants and in terms of
impacts on existing residents
um you know we're recommending to um we
re-look at the existing tro to to
understand how that might operate better
to protect existing residents so that
protection could extend to 24 hours a
day seven days seven days a week there
is a process to go through there but but
that if that were to happen then
the occupants of the new development
wouldn't be enabled wouldn't be allowed
to apply for wouldn't be granted a
parking permit for that residence only
scheme
so that would suggest that there
shouldn't be any adverse impact on
existing residents accessing an
on-street space as a result of this this
new development I know the objector
queried whether or not that policy would
apply forevermore I mean that is the
policy at the moment that the the
highway Authority worked too
whether that remains like that really is
is up to the council I mean it's not to
say that it couldn't be reviewed in the
future but I think the highway Authority
have suggested that would likely be a
decision that would have to go to full
Council
um so so there we have it it's
unfortunate that you know there isn't it
certainly isn't any accessible parking
the concept of a scheme without any
parking partly in partly just outside a
town center we think is is acceptable in
principle anyway
um particularly given the
recommendations in relation to the tro
okay thank you Mr Pierce any members
wishing to speak
foreign
thank you chair
so normally you would expect me to say
this is completely unacceptable because
there are no accessible parking spaces
and therefore I would be proposing to
turn this development down
however
I used to work at Chapel Road Clinic
and
as a blue badge holder I could park
in any parking space apart from the
residents only on Chapel Road and leave
my car there for 24 hours
and there are also the blue badge Bays
on the corner of the road
where the police station is that I use
every time I go to say a Waterside
so there's actually good provision for
accessible parking
within a very short Wheeling distance
from this property the only thing that I
would object to is calling the Masonic
Hall a non
heritage
attractive building it's terrible
and really needs demolishing so
um
offices will be shocked but I I've vote
that we
um support this
thank you
thank you councilor anybody else wishing
to speak Council deacon
but nope I like the mixture of uh
tenures and and
um the look of the scheme I think it's I
think it's really good uh and I do think
I'm I am comfortable with the um the
office of recommendation around the
existing tros
um I do think that um you know we should
be about promoting sustainable travel
behavior and
um given that it's so close to the town
center I don't perceive that being an
issue
thank you councilor Council Acton
yeah I'm very supportive of the of the
development uh you know we we need those
affordable homes
um that's been provided here
um but but
um I was worried about the parking and
and particularly for this disability but
I think
um councilor Proctor has eased my mind
around us so
I'm quite happy to second that
sorry I didn't hear a proposal did you
propose it I meant to I said vote
instead of proposed but okay thank you
councilman
Hassan I think was first yeah I fully
support this application and the only
problem I mean it's a very dense uh
congestion their regards to parking I
mean console Zach is sitting is the
constant of that part we fully
understand otherwise it is a beautiful
addition it will be as a stunning a
building for the residents and the
applicant speaker she has just said
affordable houses and we fully support
affordable houses and actually support
the officers recommendations thank you
only one issue is a parking if it is all
it's a bunch of rotations
thank you thank you Council Walton
uh yeah I agree with a lot of what's
been said already I just wanted to draw
everyone's attention to a very positive
actual um Road Safety gain which is is
that we're no longer going to have that
um the the parking that is currently
happening outside the um the police
station
um which is actually which is basically
cars illegally driving over the pavement
onto you know to reach the hard standing
and I think you can see it in some of
the some of the pictures in the uh
um that uh
the company the report
um or is it on Google Maps maybe it's
just on Google on Google Maps but it's
you know that is not going to be
possible anymore
um and therefore actually that bit of
sale is the roads and the debit of sale
is going to be um is going to be
improved in terms of road safety which I
think is a is a benefit I think
uh thank you councilor I'll just uh are
you my my one concern on this was around
the lack of accessible parking but again
it's quite separately I came to the same
conclusion as councilor Proctor due to
its location it's not it's not that big
an issue so it's been proposed and
seconded that we accept this in line
with officer recommendation all those
with their indicates
just the additional conditions oh yes
plus the additional condition which we
talked about today
yeah sorry that additional condition
um was to require a methodology for the
conversion of the police station
for the second Clarity all those in
favor including additional condition
that starts being passed in line with
officer recommendation if we move on to
the next item
on the agenda which is uh Brooklyn's
Metrolink Station Ms Milner will give
the introduction and it's on page 50 of
your pack Miss Milner thank you
thank you chair
the site is located on the southern side
of Marsden Road close to the junction
with Hope Road and brooklands Road the
land to be developed is immediately
adjacent to the former booking Hall
which is a grade two listed building the
existing building operates as a cafe and
is accessed from the bridge that crosses
over the Metrolink and Bridgewater Canal
which stairs down to the station
platforms on either side of the building
the former booking call and one to the
east to which this proposal relates is
highly visible due to its elevated
position
the applicant is seeking planning
permission for the direction of two
decked shelters with screening to
provide additional space for customers
using the cafe which is located within
the former booking call
the shelters would be Timber framed with
steel sheep roofs and sides of the
shelters and screens would be 2.3 meter
high Timber lattice structures
150 letters of support have been
received from the local community noting
the contribution the existing makes
existing business makes to the local
community and the local community
considered the proposal would enhance
the the area both visually and
economically and provide improvements to
facilities within the area
whilst officers appreciate the level of
public support and the contribution of
the existing building makes existing
business makes the site there was a
significant concern concerns over the
proposed development as outlined in the
report and additional information report
the site is highly prominent with long
views afforded due to its elevated
position the contribution of this site
to the setting of The the listed
building and views from the south south
from the bridge are considered to be of
high value and contribute strongly to
the character of the area
proposed structures would read as a
single Mass which would be wider than
the existing booking call building
when built viewed for Marsden Road it's
considered they would be in Congress and
Visually compete with the listed booking
Hall
the requirement to build a structure on
stilts because of their sighting on
astute slope
and the proposed materials would further
add to their detrimental appearance to
the local area
I would seriously detract from the
listed buildings
there are also concerns with regard to
security specifically regarding the
steps down to the station platform and
these concerns have been supported by
greater Manchester police as outlined in
the additional information report
furthermore there is concerns about the
impacts on the trees adjacent to the
site and again this is detailed within
the additional information report
ongoing ongoing discussions with the
council agriculturalist officer has
identified that the main tree adjacent
to the site is a lime tree not an elm
tree as stated on the site plan and in
the original committee report
the lime tree has been assessed for its
suitability for a tree preservation
order and that process is outlined in
the additional information report which
I would ask members to review
at this moment we have been recommended
to place a TPO on the tree not just
because of the quality of the tree but
the contribution it makes to the
character of the area and the threat
from this development
however the arbiculturalist has said
that the trigger usually for TPO is the
threat to losing the tree and therefore
has requested that if members are minded
to support the application contrary to
officer recommendation that the decision
to formally approve the scheme is
delegated to offices to allow for
further investigation work into how the
foundations of the proposed structured
would interfere with the root structure
of the light tree
if it was satisfied that the structures
could sit alongside the tree there would
be no requirement in the immediate
instance to TPO this tree
notwithstanding the comments on the tree
regarding the trees offices do consider
that the proposal would have significant
impact on the setting of the listed
building and the character of the area
as a whole
the harm to the list of buildings is
identified as less than substantial in
regards to the mppf and therefore the
harm to the listed building must be
outweighed by public benefits
officers do not consider that public
benefits have been out there identified
which would outweigh the harm to
Heritage
and the number of letters of support is
noted but this is not the basis for
making a decision it must be on planning
merits members must satisfy themselves
if they are minded to approve the scheme
that there are public benefits that
outweigh the harm to the designated
Heritage asset and the harm to the area
as a whole
officers consider
that the mppf
affords protection to this site and the
proposal would be contrary to the
development plan as a whole and
therefore recommends refusal subject to
the reasons outlined in the main report
and updated within the additional
information report thank you chair
thank you Miss Milner is Mr opinion in
the public area
because supposed to microphone you will
get three minutes
thank you
good evening Mr chairman committee
members I'm here tonight to present a
strong favorable argument for a recently
submitted planning application to create
two outdoor raised eating sort of
drinking areas associated with an
existing use at Brookfield Metrolink
station
back in 2016 an idea was generated to
create an income for a family business
in the form of a cafe and later that
year a formal planning application was
made in July 2017 planning permission
was granted to convert the Heritage
Property known as a disused ticket
office at Brooklyn's metro station to a
Hot Food Cafe for a small family
business to start
popularity has grown for this business
due to the hard work business commitment
and attitude towards customers and the
surrounding community area
due to this popularity the need for
additional floor space has been
identified and with the full support of
the commercial team at the transport for
greater Manchester a formal planning
application been made for the site and
give two outdoor raised eating drinking
areas detached from the Heritage
building currently being used
the location to propose development is
to the side of the building on a sloped
embankment that leads down to the metro
station from marslin Road and is at the
same position as the original side
extension element of the building that
has been removed and can be seen on the
historic photographs
planning application has been
unprecedented a level of support from
members of the public and elected
councils for the area in fact 136
letters emails or other direct forms of
support have been logged against this
application along with dudman's Moore
verbally offering their support
typical comments include other coffee
out of the cafe is a hub for local
residents to meet chat get some fresh
air enjoy a short break and to generally
social socialize within the community
and in this current time where mental
health is at the Forefront of many
people's minds socializing is more a
need than a want the need for this
expansion has only been generated by
public demand
care has been taken in the location of
the proposal and in the selection of
materials by using Timber lattice
screens to the sides rather than
industrial looking shutters or brickwork
a steel roof has been Incorporated with
an aesthetic finish to match the slates
on the existing building
care has been taken during we'll be
taking joy and construction by limiting
the effects of the development on the
locally sighted trees and shrubs by
minimal removal of existing Plantation
and protect and protecting the remaining
roots of the mature trees by using steel
support frame piled into the ground this
steel frame will be fully encased in
Timber panel so to prevent unsocial
Gathering spots and to prevent the
accumulation of litter this being said
modifications could be negotiated to
alter the Aesthetics in agreement with
any planner's requests to summarize this
family business is a growing Venture and
the performance development creates that
abilities to grow in a modest way that
is detached in construction from the
existing listed building and will be a
valuable asset and addition to the local
community thank you thank you
okay
Council Jones if you all
you know by now you've got five minutes
yeah thank you committee um councilor
will Jones representing Brooklyn's water
I'm speaking in support of this planet
application as a local Council of
Brooklyn's Ward on behalf of the
residents who you can see of um supports
this in great numbers
um and the community wish to keep us for
at this location as it's become
established as a community meeting place
the application's been recommended for
rejection on page four of the officer's
report because there is no scope for
amendments to the pros or therefore to
recommended the applications refused or
withdrawn obviously without any
amendments and being put in the report
and seems to be on Heritage grounds
however I call for some flexibility on
all sides to allow us for to continue to
operate from this site that they have
successfully transformed not only to
into a successful business but a
community hub for residents who meet
regularly there
there's over 150 people have written in
support of this application with no
objections which is quite remarkable for
this Cafe in this unique location
as has already been said transport for
greater Manchester support this
application and look wanted to go
forward there is obviously the issue
with the police who I believe there's
fears for plans of loitering and
nuisance and I believe this risks
probably mitigated as the plans are for
off pavement seating
um so I think that's case of four with
regard to nuisance this is probably low
risk as Captain's not a licensed value
or selling alcohol until by the
applicant there's been no police
incidents at the premises in five years
relates to the activity of us four
I feel if this planet application is
refused as recommended sale will lose a
valuable and loved meeting place
despite its statement there's no scope
for amendments the applicant and
Architects are willing to make it any
recommended changes and adaptations to
allow us for to expand in a sympathetic
manner that respects the Heritage and
look of Brooklyn's
of this Brooklyn's booking office site
some last points
um the application is also key not to
start the process again hence their
flexibility to make any changes now it's
if it's refused to withdraw and these
plans are left to be restored or
abandoned to start the plans again is
going to be a considerable cost to us
for as a business I'm sure you will
appreciate many similar businesses like
them which are small and struggling
because of energy costs and cost of
living crisis are just recovering from
the covert pandemic to such a setback of
refusing this application may make the
business unviable I'm sure we don't want
that to happen
um just some other final points and
looking at the report and it looks like
there were similar planning applications
back in the early 2010-11 which um were
approved with their
with conditions throughout ceasing areas
uncovered areas the Heritage aspects
seem to be mostly Beyond new recommended
refusal
um
I think that's it thank you
uh thank you councilor does anybody any
member wish to speak
foreign
[Music]
I thought it was licensed I'm sure that
it was um a wine list in the window and
you yeah
yeah I thought so just to to correct
that record
no no that's fine
um
yeah the the
I I'd be interested in this earlier
application of 2011.
uh I thought it was the uh knocking down
of the old concrete thing that's show
none some of the
the application
for the outdoor outdoor eating and
drinking area cited actually relate to
the pub Brooklyn's Lodge which are at a
lower level and are kind of decking area
so not this site and and there was a
retrospective application to remove the
previous extension and if I measure the
justification for that would it would
was that it would significantly improve
the appearance of the station
by removing that structure
can I listen to the discussion from
okay thank you councilor any other
member wish to speak
Council Welton
thank you
um this is a really it's a really tricky
one just because of you know you want to
support an independent business
particularly one that's obviously well
loved by you know by members of the
public and that's been clearly expressed
in all the you know all the positive
comments uh about it
um but I do think that the officer's
report is is pretty spot on
um it's it's a the structure is is
overbearing particularly when you look
from the um from the station side
um you know it is it's effectively
um you know two three three stories
um there's a large amount of work it
seems to be a large amount of wood
paneling there and and for me that is
out of context of the you know of the
the heritage of this area and that's the
principal problem with it I I'm fully
you know understand what is trying to
achieve but uh I don't think that it's
uh I I I don't think it works in the
context of this of this area I mean I I
I wish I could come with come up with a
a I'm sure lots of different solutions
have been have have been thought of but
for me that I'm looking at the car park
down below and there's three or four
cars parked there at the bottom of the
steps
um and that's place currently that space
is for cars not people and business and
that may be something that could be
reviewed um and a better place for you
to do to do something for the business
um but I think this this structure is is
not in keeping in the area
um and and therefore I would I
definitely agree with the officers
report on that basis thank you
[Music]
up thank you
if I remember it correctly in our last
meeting you know we went against the
officer advice and we supported you know
the retrospective application of chibu
restaurant in alter income which was in
a Conservation Area
um while we appreciate you know the
council's
um also focus on you know
um supporting local businesses or small
businesses as mentioned following you
know the pandemic and the rise of cost
of living plus you know the energy
prices
uh do we not have to look at
you know the application
um you know in a general sort of sense
that what will be the impact of the
applicant if we do not approve it number
one number two uh I I do read you know
the officer's recommendation and I
understand you know the effort which has
been put behind it
um all it says that there will be you
know how major harm but there is no
further you know information about that
number third Point
um as mentioned
the proposed development
is going to be like you know separated
segregated from
a-listed building so I do not personally
see any any harm being caused there the
last point from my side if there is any
room for
um Improvement in The Proposal would the
officers you know be considerate to that
thank you
Miss Milton has got some points to make
on that counselor
so I I will start and I'm sure
um Miss Holly will contribute as well so
in regards to the impact on the business
unlike the previous application we've
not had any evidence to suggest that the
business is failing and needs this for
support it's more that it wishes to grow
but notwithstanding that we are looking
at the impact on Heritage as well not
just the private interest of a business
we've got to look at the impact on the
significance of the Heritage asset this
is a grade 2 listed building so it's of
national significance and that is you
know weighed heavily in the planning
balance
in regards to you saying it's separated
from the listed building
um
yes it doesn't physically attach if it
had physically attached you'd have a
listed building consent before you so
therefore what we are looking at is the
impact on the setting of that listed
building and whilst it is
uh marginally separated it clearly
obscures the view of that listed
building and that is is the harm it
obscures the view and it harms the
setting and that in the National
planning policy framework is you know is
is a key consideration and it we afford
um harm to that setting impact on that
setting and in terms of room for
negotiation we considered this scheme at
the moment to be fundamentally
unacceptable it's not a scheme that we
can amend or suggest tweaks to it's it's
start again and those fundamental change
discussions should happen at pre-app the
applicant did not come to us at pre-app
and that is where those discussions can
and should take place
thank you Miss Milner councilor Evans
I think we need to be sympathetic with
the applicant here and in that there's
there's this place there's a one at
sales station and
there's one at timpley station and these
businesses come and go and they
fundamentally come and go because the
footprint of the buildings are just too
small to sustain a building and sustain
a wage for one person two people for a
good announce that planning
consideration but actually the
sympathetic wooden structure on the back
of this building not attached to it the
view at the back of the building isn't
fabulous we've got the new steps uh that
new brickwork's not exactly pretty
um isn't in my view gonna
detract from it too much and actually it
probably will do
uh long-term benefit to the actual
building because if we've got a
sustainable business there because it's
got a bigger footprint they'll be able
to maintain the building in a better
state so although we'll be losing some
visual immediency as we see here
um actually I'm sure it's not going to
be a hideous construction and actually
quite you know reasonable wooden
construction could look quite nice so I
I would be supporting the applicant
going against the office I think we need
to consider these businesses need space
in order to trade and make a proper
living thank you thank you Council
acting yeah I do think it's a difficult
one this
um there seems to be a lot of community
support for it I'm not convinced uh
about the buildings that they want to
build you know in mainly in Wood which
does distract really from from the
building itself
um
I just think it's probably the wrong
structure but I think that if they
looked at something else that
um could make some kind of cover to
you know to to to enable people to sit
uh as they sit sit outside there
at this present time but you know
through the winter and all of that you
know it's a different matter isn't it so
I just
would like to support it but I I don't
think we should go against a Heritage
issues on this particular
um building that they're proposing but I
would hope that they could have
discussions with the planners to look at
something that would be more appropriate
and agreeable
thank you councilor if the two councils
weren't speakers with me for a second if
I could just give my view on this my
view is it's a it's a great location for
an expansion in the business but the
proposal which is in front of us will
indubitably detract from the the
Heritage aspect of the building that's
already there
um and I'm also conscious of the the
items in the additional information
report where the police are raising
objections to this in terms of the
safety aspects of the building in place
so I have no no problem in principle
with something here but I don't think
this is the scheme I will be voting in
line with officer recommendation
customers
um we pretty much some of what I was
about to say but um the thing is yeah I
think that we do need to have I can
understand the want for having a shelter
a sheltered area and make more space
effectively I completely understand it
um
the difficulty is is I mean for the you
know there's two big ones the ones that
one is the Heritage but really really
concerning is the is the safety aspect
that the police have raised and you know
do we want to be creating effectively
hot spots of where someone could get
potentially be attacked
um I think that we need to
those those safety concerns actually
outweigh I'm afraid
um the the you know what what what the
business wants to do I think that if
they can find some find a way I don't
know what the answer is exactly but it's
clearly there isn't a tweaking to be
done as was Melania said there isn't a
tweaking that can be done to the current
proposal
um because
it is to start again to get something
that would work and be be safe for for
people using
um you know using the stairs we have to
that has to come first
um above I think
um the benefits to the the business and
even the you know the users of the
business I think if you could find
another scheme
that is safe then that then I'll be
really really happy to see that to be
honest and and I would be supportive of
that but it is the current one I'm
afraid I can't
so it was that proposal that we refused
that we refuse this yes thank you
cash accordingly
[Music]
thank you
um yeah
um
I'm going to be supporting refusal but
the reason I still want to speak is that
in terms of the Heritage app aspect and
that this particular picture behind you
is a useful one
I don't I've got to confess that those
rear two panels
uh off the station don't look that
attractive they look like brick filled
and I suspect they've always been there
but they are not that attractive
my problem is the stairs the lights and
the paneling
the Heritage aspect
if a good plan plan came up
and it blank it it took away looking at
those last two panels I would not
be so strongly backing up the Heritage
aspect what I am bothered about is those
lights we don't know what's going to
happen that part that path is not just
uh for commuters it leads to Brooklyn's
Cemetery you know there are there are
sensitive people going through and they
will be emerging into a a drinking area
um I I and eating and drinking area
which may not be appropriate to that I
think that's doable I don't think I
don't even think the stairs are the most
accessible answer but if something was
to be done with those stairs again I
would be look I would be more
happy to support a plant if that makes
sense and I want lighting for the users
of the Walk
I don't like the paneling I suspect it
will deteriorate quickly
it could even get the odd panel being
kicked in
and it it has an area underneath that I
don't like you know I I'm an old enough
guy who remembers Bradfield Bradford
fire disaster
and it's got that sort of feel to it
it's got an area underneath that could
collect rubbish if the panels were
removed and things like that so I don't
think this is the right design but I am
not so precious about the view I don't
if if it's all about the Heritage aspect
I don't think that's capturing my
objection and that that would be my one
comment are you second in re to refuse
and Loud loss of recommendation
okay uh we'll move this along move to
the vote we've had a proposed and
seconded that will refuse in line with
officer recommendation all those in
favor of fusion please indicate
[Music]
so we have refused that in line with
officer recommendation uh thank you
members
the next item on the agenda is uh
crossford Bridge Playing Fields Mr
Pearson we'll get the introduction and
it's on page 101 of the pack
[Music]
thank you chairman uh
this application relates to an existing
football pitch car park and connecting
access path within the crossford bridge
playing field site and sail
the application seeks planning
permission for the erection of an
artificial grass pitch with Associated
pyramid of fencing flood lighting and a
storage container
also proposes the extension of the
existing car park with Associated
perimeter barriers lighting and
Landscaping
it's proposed to provide a pedestrian
access path to connect the extended car
park to the Athletics Pavilion as well
as a resurface driveway from the
Athletics track car park to the
artificial grass pitch entrance with
Associated lighting
whilst The Proposal represents
inappropriate development in Greenbelt
terms and identified harm to the
greenvelt has been given substantial
weight for public benefits referenced in
the committee report are considered to
be of sufficient Merit to constitute the
very special circumstances necessary for
the development to be deemed acceptable
in this respect
issues associated with parking crime
noise and light pollution have been
raised it representation representations
by local residents however however these
matters have been considered and found
to be acceptable in planning terms
subject to appropriate conditions where
relevant
The Proposal complies with a development
plan in all of the respects which
indicates that planning permission
should be granted without delay
the proposed development is considered
to be acceptable in terms of its design
and visual impacts its impact on
residential amenity including in
relation to noise and lighting issues
its Highway impacts and with regards to
all other material planning
considerations
there are no material considerations to
indicate that planning permissions
should be refused and as such the
application is recommended for approval
subject to conditions thank you
uh thank you Mr Pearson if I kick off
the debates on this one I have no
hesitation at all in recommending we go
along with officer's recommendation on
this it takes an existing Sports field
admittedly in the green belt but it's
already in the green belt and adds lots
and lots of facilities to the side I
understand residence concern around
noise and lighting and all the rest of
it but I think it's well well covered in
the report with any other memo is to
speak
cancer acting just to support
support it for the reasons that you've
given
thank you councilor
councilor Walsh thanks chair we are
building on Greenbelt here and um our
planning office is right at least tell
us that we don't approve inappropriate
development on Greenbelt
don't worry I'm not going against the
officer recommendation I can see a few
scary eyes there
um the benefits do do outweigh those
concerns we normally around Greenbelt a
year
football you know it's an important past
time I went down on Saturday and I saw
the lads playing in the area where the
artificial pitch is going to go and the
floodlights
and it will be a well-used facility
so floodlights are going to be there
it's going to be used in the evening we
want it to be used in the evening
and when I read the report I could see
the conditions that have been added to
the application around noise and power
and parking any issues the residents
have
they can bring them to the council they
can bring them to the operator and uh
and they will be dealt with so I was I
was comfortable with that we didn't want
people being disturbed of an evening so
I think this is a good facility it's
certainly well used now hence it's got
to it's got to expand and um very much
support the application chair thank you
thank you councilor anybody else wishing
to speak
okay well in the absence of a proposal
in the second I'm happy to propose we're
accepted alignment officer
recommendation uh councilor Walsh is
seconded in live with us recommendation
all those in favor can indicate
thank you members make that unanimous
on the agenda which is
uh the Bowling Green and actually Road
and hail Miss Coley will do the
introduction and it's on page 135 of the
pack thank you
um
brought to the planning committee in
view of the council's interest in the
land the application relates to the size
of the new multifunctional community
building in hail planning permission is
sought for a small extension to an
outdoor Terrace this would provide the
Bowling Club within a large seating and
spectator area The Proposal would result
in a strip of lawn being removed from
the Bowling Green the resultant green
would still make the sports required
dimensions and there would be no loss in
its function the Bowling Green also
holds visual immunity value it is an
undesignated Heritage asset and it is
cited within a Conservation Area whilst
the loss of some of the green
is regarded as regrettable the Heritage
harm would be negligible in view of the
small-scale nature of the works the
development proposed would provide some
public benefits and it is concluded that
these benefits would outweigh the
Heritage harm any noise arising from the
extended Terrace could be controlled via
conditions it has been concluded the
proposal is acceptable in all respects
to compliant with the development plan
and National policy approval with
conditions is therefore recommended
thank you
ah thank you Miss Coley does any member
wish to kick off the debate
councilor Walsh thank you I'll step in
chair if everybody's hesitating
um I'll give you a bit of history when
it was the mayor I actually attended an
event at uh at this location and
welcomed very well by the the Bowling
Club I'm very supportive of this
application perhaps I should be
declaring an interesting I'd send it as
the mayor
um it felt to me like a bit of an
oversight if if you visit the site you
see the Pavilion and then the Bowling
Green appears and it just seems you
would have thought about that previously
but it's the Bowling Green that of a
bowling club that have applied for this
um and again the
to talk to previously a very well used
facility lots of people enjoying the
ball and it's a lovely location and I
very much support the application chair
thank you
thank you Council anyone else
councilman
thank you Council Welton I also am very
much in favor of this like counselor
Walsh felt like a bit of an oversight
which we're now put in right so we've
been proposed and seconded that we
approve in live lobster recommendation
roll out in favor to indicate
make that unanimous thank you members
that concludes that item of the on the
agenda now move on to section seven uh
traffic design code where Miss Coley
will give an introduction to the uh the
coders in our stands
thank you chair if I
if I could plug in
um what I'm what I'm going to do members
is
um
presume that you've read the report
um and you know what's coming but just
actually just take you through the
website so you understand how it works
um
yes
so the council's executive approved the
draft design code last month at their
beating
the consultation began on the 3rd of
July and is underway and runs all the
way till the 25th of September so we
decided we'd do a month before and the
month after the summer so that
um we wouldn't receive any complaints
that we were Consulting over over the
summer so
the show this is the this is effectively
the landing page so this is what you see
albeit the code works on
um
laptops it works on iPads it works on
your phone as well so it will it will
automatically change
the
thing to be aware of here and I think
what I'll do is I'll go into one of the
pages and show you this is It's
interactive and fully accessible so you
could do all sorts of things changing
the text in all sorts of different ways
and it does Dyslexia friendly
so it changes through so
so lots and lots of different
accessibility settings for the actual
website itself so that people can use it
and if somebody wanted a text only
version
you've got that's a pen
sorry
um
you can just generate that straight out
and you've got the full coverage
effectively cover to cover
thing so if I take you through to
so the first thing that people can do is
learn how to use the code so there's
instructions
about how it works
what you should read so
if you're doing external spaces then you
might want to look at these two chapters
if you're doing development sites with
many buildings on it then you might want
to look at these two chapters that's all
taken through all of that
tells you how to use a design code
itself so it sets out what each of these
are
and explain to them
foreign
how to use it
then there's a glossary
the end
so of all the technical words
I believe these are official definitions
and where they're not they're just
sensible straightforward ones
but if if you're a layperson using this
then then anything you you're not sure
about you can have a look at
um
of course ask away anybody
does
it
to pass on the disappointments of one of
our local architects who
said that their firm was never contacted
about the architect's consultation
session and he heard about it from word
of mouth and somebody else from another
further so I'm just wondering you know
what's everything that could have been
done and done under contact with a
little
we we wrote to every architect firm that
we are we are know about we wrote to
very very many
um Architects and agents and if you let
me know afterwards who it was then we
can invite them to come next Wednesday
to the developers Forum if they would
prefer because it will be the same
okay
yeah let me know who it is afterwards
counseling up
this is about the conversation now this
is out for consultation now
um there are Community drop it if you
see here there's Community drop-in
events in September
which anybody is welcome to
and one in the South one in the north
yeah Castle Proctor thanks I tried to
look for it on the council website and I
couldn't it only took me to these are
the consultation events so I copied the
web address
so how do people access this if if they
can't do it through Trafford site
you should it's got its own web address
yes and I see that but when I went on I
tried to find it by the Trafford website
on the on the council site and I put in
and traffic design code all I got was
Community engagement sessions there
wasn't a link to this okay it should be
on our strategic planning pages but I
will check that counselor that's no
problem because you're right we should
you should be able to get through that
way if you need to thanks
downside yes that'll be awesome
things going off yes I don't see why not
we can we can make it a lot more visible
on on the website that's that's no
problem the great thing is we've got
complete control over this this website
so we can put obviously within reason
anything we want on here and link to and
from our website so that's that's no
problem
um what I'll do is I'll just show you
one of the codes I'll show you the
accessibility one
um given the
strong interest of this committee quite
rightly in accessibility
so this is the accessibility for houses
so
um there's an introduction which gives
some general guidance and why we're
doing you know why this code is in
then there's some examples and these
things
you can play with
so you can spin around and look at not
very easy with a touch with a
probably
yeah it's probably easy with the mouse
and not being me
um
sorry
right up right I'll stop stop that so
you've got these slider things so you
can see how you might adapt to a house
to make it
um more accessible in the future so
um if you slide it across you see that
the bathroom extends and then that room
on the left hand side you look at it
becomes a bedroom
and then there's a natural standards so
we've got m42
and reference to the emerging local plan
for m43 and a link to the part M so
people know what they need to do
um then you've got
foot ways
five different things sorry for about
more than that eight eight different
things that you can do to make footwears
more accessible
parking and this is for houses by the
way there's another set for apartments
but I won't go through both of those and
once this is adopted this is now this
becomes a applicable to all our planning
application it does yes okay brilliant
so
that's that so yeah it will it will
become a material consideration an
important material consideration as well
because the mppf says you determine
applications in accordance with adopted
design guides and codes
um encourage all members to get involved
with the consultation The Citizen Space
questionnaire is designed so you can you
don't have to answer every question you
can just do the bits that you're
interested in
um
you can do free text responses happy at
any point between now and the 25th of
September if you spot any typos if you
see anything that that isn't working
properly please do just let us know
um and we and we can sort that out and
uh and deal with it but I think the
other thing is to start getting
yourselves familiar with it because it
will start being referred to more and
more in reports as we get closer to
adoption and once it is adopted it will
be
um the main way of assessing design in
proposals so it will be in
um 95 of you committee reports
and uh we but again we can do we can do
some training on that later in the year
as well so okay thanks thank you thank
you Miss Coley thanks for all the work
let's go into this big I'm a big fan of
the uh design code and it also encourage
people to go through the consultation
process either online or I've been to a
couple of the in-person ones they're
really usual to have the office in the
room to to have a to have a chat with
okay thank you for asking for me
lots of people have read this 1.7 of
your of your report the design Council
are making arrangements with officers to
use Trafford as a best practice case
study on the website including producing
a short film about Trafford and the code
I think that's good work from our
planning officers and it needs to be
said and that's not a straightforward
thing that a lot of work's gone into
that and it's uh and they've been
rewarded with a and and other planning
authorities will learn from it so let's
just say from all of us well done to the
planning team
thank you Lawrence
um so if we now move on to the final
item a virgin business which is just a
little bit of housekeeping we need to
sort out
over to you Miss Coley thank you uh the
Urgent business item was emailed round
to you earlier today it's
um
it's straightforward in we have a
validation checklist which is uh a list
of information requirements which are
required to accompany planning
applications when they're submitted and
there's a national requirement which is
statutory and then local requirements
and you have to review your application
validation checklist every two years and
the most recent review was June 21.
um
all we wish to do this time around is
republish the um validation checklist
unchanged uh because we want to do a
more comprehensive view to go along with
the design code and the requirements for
compliance which will go into the
validation checklist later in the year
um but there is no point preempting that
by doing doing that now so members are
just asked to approve the republication
of the validation checklist and changed
in order that
um before the more fundamental review we
can still ask for local information
requirements and we could and we can
still ask for the information we require
planning applications to enable good
decision making and and also more Speedy
decision making thank you
uh thank you Miss Coley so can we take
that as accepted that we keep the
because they currently stand no need to
provoke I think we'll take that on the
eye okay thank you members I conclude
the business of tonight thank you all
for coming thank you for for all the
contributions appreciate it thanks
bye-bye
thank you